>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mark Dimunation:
I'm very pleased
to launch the program this
morning with a few words
of welcome from the Library.
Mark Sweeney was named
Acting Deputy Librarian
of Congress soon after the
appointment of Carla Hayden
as the new Librarian
of Congress.
Previously, Mark served
as the Associate Librarian
for Library Services.
This position, in essence,
is the National Librarian.
He was responsible and
still is for carrying
out Library Services' mission
which is to acquire, organize,
provide access to, maintain,
secure and preserve the Library
of Congress' universal
collection
of over 140 million items.
This vast collection
contributes to the advancement
of civilization and knowledge
throughout the world.
Documents the history and
culture of the United States
and records and supports
the creativity
of the American people.
Mark is one of us.
He hails from McGill University
and has worked his way
through the ranks of the
Library beginning in 1987 --
I know that was a
long time ago --
in the serial and government
publications division.
He soon advanced to Coordinator
of the very important United
States Newspaper Program
and then to Chief
of the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division of
the Library of Congress and then
to the Director of the Library's
Preservation Program before he
moved into the Associate
Librarian position.
He is a valiant advocate
of the collections
and it was his support
in large part
which made this symposium
possible.
So please welcome
Acting Deputy Librarian
of Congress Mark Sweeney.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Sweeney: Good
morning, everyone.
It's my pleasure to
welcome you to the Library
of Congress' Symposium,
Imagining the Extraordinary
Scientific Illustration
from the Renaissance
to the Digital Age.
Over the next two days,
you will hear from experts
across the humanities, the arts
and sciences discuss
the different ways
that creative scientific
illustration has extended the
reach of human understanding
about the natural world.
And as Mark mentioned
later today,
you'll have an exciting
opportunity to view select items
from our Rare Book Collection
both historical and contemporary
that intersect and
illustrate discovery.
So it's really a remarkable
opportunity for you,
if I hope you have
an opportunity
to take advantage of that.
So in many ways, this symposium
speaks to what makes the Library
of Congress such a
unique institution.
As the largest library in the
world, we maintain stewardship
over millions of items in
a dizzying array of topics.
And with over 20 reading rooms,
our expert staff
have an opportunity
to make this incredibly
vast collection accessible.
Sometimes, it's challenging
to find creative ways
to bring our different
expertise into the conversation
and to share the
Library's vast physical
and intellectual
resources with users.
Imagining the Extraordinary,
today's program and tomorrow's,
speaks to this primary mission.
Inspired by Library collection,
this symposium brings
together experts
from multiple disciplines
to talk about everything
from the unimaginably large
to the inconceivably small.
I really want to thank
and acknowledge staff
that put together this program
today especially the Rare Book
Division obviously and
Stephanie Stillo who played
such a large part in it as
well as Mark Dimunation.
And I want to thank our staff
of our special collection,
our Special Events Office
for organizing this.
And also, of course,
the Library wants
to thank the Gladys
Kriebel Delmas Foundation
for their support
of this symposium.
Without their support,
it wouldn't be possible.
So it's in this spirit of
inclusion and discovery
that we welcome you to
the nation's library.
I thank you for being here
and I hope you have what
I suspect will be a very
enlightening two days.
So thank you very
much and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Stillo:
All right, good morning.
My name is Stephanie Stillo and
I am delighted to welcome you
to Imagining the Extraordinary.
This symposium has
been a long time
in the making for our division.
So I am so pleased to be able
to share it with you today
and those that are
to come, I guess,
a little bit later
this afternoon.
I must say you're in
for quite a treat.
Our speakers are truly inspired
and we're just delighted
to welcome them to the Library.
So before we begin,
I'd like to, of course,
also thank the Gladys
Kriebel Delmas Foundation
for their support.
I'm sure as many of you know,
keeping these events free
and open to the public
requires a fair amount
of financial assistance
and we're very grateful
to the Delmas Foundation
for their generosity.
I'd also like to
thank the Library
of Congress Events Committee
particularly Kimberly Crawford
and Mary Eno for helping
organize this event.
And lastly, thanking Helena
Zinkham and of course,
Mark Sweeney, for supporting
the Rare Books Division
in their vision of this program.
So as I mentioned, my
name is Stephanie Stillo.
And I am the curator,
the lucky curator
of the Lessing J.
Rosenwald Collection
in the Rare Books Division
here at the Library.
The Rosenwald Collection is
an ambitious graphic arts
collection with thematic
concentrations and everything
from the history of science
to the decorative arts.
In many ways, the Rosenwald
Collection and the vision
of the man who created it,
was the inspiration
for this symposium.
Lessing Rosenwald was a
collector that was inspired
by the history of printing.
And how that technology
encouraged historical change.
He celebrated this interest by
collecting illustrated books
that documented or sometimes
created shifts in taste
and intellectual tradition
over the last five centuries.
Now, as someone with a
purely humanities background,
I found Lessing's
collected books
on science particularly exotic.
Euclid's Elements of Geometry,
Vesalius' Human Dissections,
[Inaudible] impossibly
complex celestial
and geometric calculators,
Galileo's moon.
I wanted to find a way to
talk about these books,
about the profound and
excited dialogue that had
such a massive historical
impact.
And I eventually
realized that my interest
in these books really were
their images and the ability
of these images to convey
meaning hundreds of years
after their publication.
And it was this interest
that inspired this symposium.
So the harbingers
of historic shifts
and scientific understanding
were often changes in methods
of image production, from wood
to metal, from metal to stone,
from stone to the wide-ranging
methods of photomechanical
and photographic production.
It was these images, flawed
as they may have been,
that most people
experienced new,
heady and exciting revelations
in mathematics, physics,
biology and the cosmos.
Now, in 2018, digital tools
are sounding the trumpets
of a new chapter in the history
of scientific illustration.
While Robert Hooke's
engravings brought us dozens
of miniscule phenomena,
the point of a needle,
a strand of silk, the barbs
of a stinging nettle --
digital visualization
tools can now envision
and circulate images
of infinitesimal
yet vast and unique bioscapes.
And visualize structural
variations
within the human genome.
The speakers here today and
tomorrow will discuss this long
and varied history of
scientific illustration,
of intellectual dialogue,
of radicalism and orthodoxy,
of artistic and technological
innovation.
But within all of these talks,
we find gratifyingly
common questions.
How do we imagine the universe
and our place within it?
How can we capture the
wonder and the mystery
of the natural world
and the human body?
How do very human choices
in illustration processes
impact public understanding?
I'd like to think that
this symposium is our way
of celebrating this
complicated history
and these complicated questions.
Over the next two days, you
will hear historians talking
about finding our
place in the universe.
Artists will address
scientific convention.
Biologists will talk
about breakthroughs
in historic illustration
and technologists will face the
frontiers of cultural heritage,
storytelling and access.
It's in this spirit of
dialogue and discovery
that we warmly welcome you to
Imagining the Extraordinary.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I would now like to
invite our colleague
from the Folger Shakespeare
Library,
Caroline Duroselle-Melish
on stage
to introduce our first speaker.
>> Caroline Duroselle-Melish:
Good morning.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Roger Gaskell.
Gaskell is an antiquarian
bookseller based
in England specializing
in scientific medical
and technical books.
But this is only a
part of his resume.
Gaskell has also been sharing
with others his vast knowledge
of books on science, not only
through his Dealers'
Catalogues but through teaching.
He is an affiliate of the
Department of the History
and Philosophy of Science at
the University of Cambridge
where he teaches a
regular seminar entitled
"Science in Print."
He also teaches courses on
illustrated scientific books
at the Bodleian Library
in Oxford
and at the Rare Book
School at the University
of Virginia in Charlottesville.
He has published widely
on printing history
and the bibliographical
book illustrations.
Recently, he built a replica of
an 18th century rolling press
which is now at the
University of Virginia.
Gaskell is also interested
in the history of libraries
and in working on an edition
of the library catalogue
of the Royal College of
Physicians of London,
first published in 1660.
The title of Roger's talk is
"How Books Shape the Universe,
The Impact of the
Printed Image."
Please join me in
welcoming Roger Gaskell.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roger Gaskell: Good
morning and thank,
Stephanie for inviting
me to come and speak.
I'm absolutely thrilled
to be here.
Thank you, Caroline,
for that introduction.
It's a little bit of -- it
feels rather a responsibility
to be asked to go first.
But on the other hand,
then on reflection,
I thought, "Well, yes.
But then by the end
of the seminar,
you'll all have forgotten
what I had to say."
So it's not such a risk, I hope.
So, with that, well let's
just hope for the best.
Let's hope for the best.
The night sky has always
been a source of wonder,
of mystery and of utility.
In the ancient world, it was
important to map the heavens
and learn the movements of
the wandering stars, the sun
and moon, and Mercury, Venus,
Mars, Jupiter, and Saturn.
Timekeeping, planning the
farming year, the calendar
of religious festivals,
navigation
and astrological divination
were motivations enough
for serious scientific
study of the heavens.
But science has always also
been motivated by curiosity,
by wonder, by the beauty
of the natural world.
As Nicolaus Copernicus puts
it in the first sentence
of De revolutionibus , "Among
the many various literary
and artistic pursuits which
invigorate men's minds,
the strongest affection and
utmost zeal should, I think,
promote the studies concerned
with the most beautiful objects,
most deserving to be known.
What indeed is more beautiful
than heaven, which of course,
contains all things of beauty?"
I want to stress this aspect of
scientific discovery, curiosity,
wonder, the aesthetics.
Because as well as
being a driving force
to scientific inquiry, it
is also to a greater extent
than is sometimes
appreciated, a driving force
in the making of
scientific books.
A young person visiting a
literary home cast his eyes
over the thousands of
books lining the walls
and on the tables.
He asked nervously, "Have
you read all these books?"
His host's reply, "I have never
bought a book I did not intend
to read."
[Laughter] This is the
secret of publishing.
You have to sell more books than
are actually going to be read.
In this, pictures
play a major role.
Pictures sell books.
Historians of science
sometimes forget this.
And this is one of the reasons
that images can get overlooked.
I'm going to look at three kinds
of astronomical images which are
of some importance to the
development of astronomy,
to our understanding of
our place in the universe,
and to our appreciation
of its beauty.
The images are mostly well-known
but by looking at them
from the point of view of
their origins, the technology
of their production
and their impact
on the nonprofessional readers,
I hope to give you some hints
about their place
in cultural history,
not just the grand
narrative of the development
of astronomy told by
intellectual historians.
Three things are essential
to understanding the heavens
and they will require
the use of images.
First, we need a map
of the fixed stars.
Only once their positions are
known can we track the movements
of the wandering stars, the
strange dance of the planets
as they advance in one
direction and then loop back.
So that's my first topic.
My second topic is a geometrical
model of these movements,
the heliocentric
system of Copernicus.
And finally, I want to look
at the first investigations
of the heavens not with geometry
but by direct observation
with the telescope, Galileo's
Siderius Nuncius of 1610.
So let's start with star maps.
The night sky is
a confusing sight.
In order to make
some sense of it,
it became traditional
probably in prehistoric times
to group together stars that
suggested the shapes of animals,
gods or mythological figures.
And these are the
constellations.
They are arbitrary
groups of stars
but they provide a framework
defining star positions verbally
with descriptions such
as the Bright Star
in the right shoulder of Orion.
More accurate positions would
be provided by coordinates
but the verbal descriptions
as well as the names
for specific stars
continue to be used
and constellation
figures continue
to be prominent features
on star maps,
even for professional
astronomers
into the 19th century.
And they're still important
for amateur astronomers.
Constellation figures with star
positions were first printed
in Venice in 1482 in
the mythological poem,
"Poeticon Astronomicon"
attributed
to the Roman historian
Gaius Julius Hyginus.
But the stars dotted about
the constellation figures have
little to do with their
real positions in the sky.
Albrecht Durer's famous woodcut
celestial maps of the northern
and southern hemispheres --
we're just looking at
the northern one here --
are the first printed maps
with accurate star positions.
The lettering on
the map credits --
well, actually, it's not
on the map but anyway.
I think it may be
on the other map.
But well, the contributors
to the map are credited
as Johannes Stabius,
who is astronomer
to Maximillian the First,
who drew the coordinate grid,
the Nuremberg astronomer
Conrad Heinfogel,
who positioned the stars on
the grid, and finally, Durer,
who drew the constellation
figures around the stars.
The image is printed from a
large, a very large woodblock.
It's about 17 inches wide.
And it would have been executed
by a professional block
cutter, not by Durer himself.
So the print is a collaboration
between at least four people.
And we should bear this in
mind when loosely referring it
to as -- referring to it
as Durer's planisphere.
The sun, moon and planets move
within a band of sky known
as the zodiac which is tilted at
an angle to the Earth's equator.
Here, you can see the
familiar constellations
of the zodiac arranged
anti-clockwise
around the graduated circle.
Durer's constellation figures
are shown from the back
as if we were looking
at the celestial sphere
from the outside as if
looking at a celestial globe.
These designs for the
constellation figures were
important models for
later celestial mapmakers.
In the corners of the print,
you can see the four depictions
of ancient authorities
on the sky.
So we have the Greek poet
Aratus, the Roman poet Manilius,
Al-Sufi, who is an
astronomer working
in Baghdad in the 10th century.
And finally, looking
suspiciously
like the Mad Hatter
is Claudius Ptolemy.
Ptolemy was of Greek
origin and he wrote in Greek
but because he -- but he
became a Roman citizen
and lived in Alexandria.
So this is why he's referred to
on the map as Ptolemy of Egypt.
Ptolemy's textbook,
the Almagest ,
written in the 2nd
century CE is one
of the most influential
scientific treatises
of all time.
Although an epitome
was published in 1496,
the full text was not in print
until 1515, the same year
as the woodcut planisphere.
The Almagest contains a
catalogue of fixed stars
and a geometrical
model of the universe
with the stationary
Earth at the center.
This model is known as
the Ptolemaic system.
Ptolemy arranged his catalogue
of 1022 stars in
48 constellations.
Star locations within the
constellations are given
verbally on the left and
by coding it for longitude
and latitude in degrees with a
scale of brightness or magnitude
from one, the brightest
to six, the faintest.
These are in the
table on the right.
Ptolemy's constellations
and star catalogue
actually lasted longer
than his planetary system
for while the geocentric model
was replaced, although not
without a struggle
by the heliocentric sun-centered
model put forward by Copernicus
in the 16th century, most
of Ptolemy's constellations
are still in use today.
Although Durer's planispheres
are the first printed star maps,
the first set of charts in
book form to show the positions
of the stars relative
to one another accurately is
Piccolomini's De le stelle
fisse, printed at
Venice in 1540.
The magnitude of each star is
indicated by the use of symbols.
So these maps are a
graphic representation
of Ptolemy's catalogue, the
numerical coordinates translated
into positions and the
magnitudes into symbols.
It was another 50 years
before Giovanni Paolo Gallucci
published the first star atlas
to combine constellation figures
with accurate star positions.
So now, we have all the elements
of the typical star atlas.
A series of maps with
constellation figures,
accurate star positions,
and a system of coordinates.
Gallucci took his star positions
from the catalogue printed
at the end of Copernicus'
De revolutionibus of 1543.
Copernicus made a few
corrections to Ptolemy based
on fresh observations and he
changed the coordinate system.
But his catalogue is
essentially Ptolemy's catalogue.
The images on these two small
Venetian atlases, Piccolomini
and Gallucci, are
like the planisphere
with constellation
figures designed
by Durer printed
from woodblocks.
Very different in appearance is
Uranometria of Johann Bayer
printed at Augsburg in 1603.
Here you see the elaborate
engraved title page
and here is one of the maps.
This is one of the most
beautiful star atlases
and the first to
have charts printed
from copper plate engraving.
It was also the most
accurate to date being based
on the star positions calculated
by the Danish astronomer
Tycho Brahe from new
and highly accurate
observations.
As well as using these more
accurate positions established
by the Danish astronomer,
Bayer also introduced a
new system of nomenclature.
In each constellation, he gave
the principal stars the letters
of the Greek alphabet in
descending order of magnitude.
Thus the star in Orion's left
shoulder is Alpha Orionis.
Being one of the
brightest stars in the sky,
it also has its own
name, Betelgeuse.
But most stars do not
have individual names
and Bayer's nomenclature
is important
and still in use today.
But above all, Bayer
provided the first really
accurate plates.
Gallucci had shown the way by
providing scales and gridlines
but his small page
size and the costliness
of the woodcut illustrations
meant
that his star positions could
not be read off the plate
with any accuracy.
Bayer's much larger
plates and the finer lines
of engraving allowed him
to achieve a quite new
level of precision.
The plates are about
18 inches wide.
So if you compare these with
Gallucci's page which is
about seven inches wide,
but Bayer's atlas is still
small compared to later atlases.
John Flamsteed's atlas of
1729 is almost twice as wide
as Bayer's at 32 inches and
some atlases were even bigger.
The plates are generally
attributed
to the German engraver
Alexander Mayer around early use
of stipple engraving where the
image is made up of small dots.
This is the perfect technique
for rendering the constellation
figures so that they are easy
to read without interfering
with the star symbols
and their lettering.
Bayer's atlas was important
for practicing astronomers.
We know that when Flamsteed
of the Royal Greenwich
Observatory made his great
3000-star catalogue, beginning
his observations in the 1670s,
he used Bayer's charts to
locate the naked eye stars,
filling in the new
telescopic stars between them.
But as with most books,
professional users make
up only part of the market.
These well-drawn and finely
engraved mythological figures
would have appealed to buyers
of other high-end
illustrated books.
Important for the publisher
of what must have been a very
expensive book to produce.
So I'll the evolution of
star atlases with here
with Bayer's atlas published
in 1603 representing the
situation just a few years
before Galileo started
looking at the heavens
through his telescope.
But before we get to Galileo,
what about the wandering stars
whose movements are defined
with reference to
the fixed stars?
This diagram is one
of the most famous
in the history of science.
It is, of course,
the heliocentric.
It is, of course, the
heliocentric model
of the universe in Nicolaus
Copernicus De revolutionibus
orbium coelestium
or The Revolutions
of the Heavenly Spheres
published at Nuremberg in 1543.
This is the diagram that
shows that our world is not
at the center of the universe
but just one among the other
five known planets circling
the sun.
One of the advantages
of the new system was
that it made it possible to
compute periods and distances
of the planets from the sun.
The diagram shows how
elegantly this works.
With the planets ordered
by the time each takes
to orbit the sun related to its
relative distance from the sun.
The period of each
planet is given
in the legend on each circle.
The outermost planet,
Saturn, has a period
of 30 years then comes Jupiter
at 12 years, Mars at two years,
Earth, one year, of course
and the inner planets,
Venus and Mercury with periods
of nine months and 80 days.
The outermost sphere is labeled
Stellarum Fixarum sphaera
immobilis, the immovable
sphere of the fixed stars.
I want you to remember
this phrase,
the immovable sphere
of the fixed stars.
Copernicus had been working
on his treatise for many years
when the young Joachim Rheticus
arrived at the monastery
in Frombork in Poland where
Copernicus was a priest.
This was in 1539.
This neatly written manuscript
was completed two years later
in 1541.
It seems to be a presentation
manuscript, not printer's copy.
And it certainly was
not the manuscript
that went to the printer.
A copy was made after
Rheticus had left Frombork
and sent to him in Nuremberg.
At some point, some very
interesting changes were made
to this famous diagram.
What we are familiar with in
the printed book is not what is
in Copernicus' own manuscript.
In the manuscript,
there are eight circles.
But in the woodcut,
there are nine circles.
An extra circle has been
introduced within the sphere
of the Earth with a sphere
for the moon around it.
I'm sure you can -- so sorry.
So there is the Earth,
Telluris com Luna but here,
it's now got its own circle and
an extra circle for the moon.
Copernicus believed that
the planets were carried
around in solid orbs.
The introduction of a circle
in the Earth's sphere implies
something quite different.
Not a solid sphere in rotation
but the Earth moving
freely through space.
The line in the diagram
indicating an orbital path.
Since Rheticus oversaw
the printing
of De revolutionibus in
Nuremberg or at any rate,
in the early stages,
he presumably supplied
the block cutter
with a sketch to work from.
In this case, he would
have been responsible
for introducing the
circle for the Earth
and the subsidiary
circle for the moon.
Innumerable textbook diagrams
supposedly illustrating the
Copernican system followed this
and showed the planets
positioned
on the circles rather
than between them.
Copernicus actually
thought that the planets --
of the planets being carried
around in solid spheres
within which they had
further complex movements.
Just as in the Ptolemaic
system, in the Copernican model,
the planets moved in small
circle called "epicycles"
at the same time as being
carried around in their spheres.
This was necessary to account
for their looping dance.
The ambiguous woodcut in De
revolutionibus is responsible
for the misconception that the
Copernican system involved the
planets moving through
space along circular paths
without epicycles and
therefore more elegant
than Ptolemy's system which
also required epicycles.
In fact, orbital paths without
epicycles were not introduced
until later in the
century by Johannes Kepler.
Then something curious happens
outside the sphere of the Earth.
The next ring is empty
so this ring is empty.
And all the lettering has now
been shifted to the outside
of the lines compared to how
it was in the manuscript.
So the lettering
from Mars, Jupiter,
Saturn are now sitting
on the lines.
And so by analogy with the
Earth's path, they seem also
to indicate not solid
spheres but orbital paths.
But shifting the
lettering to the outside
of the circle has another
highly significant effect.
The sphere of the fixed stars
no longer has any boundary.
This, I think, gave a hint
for another significant
reinterpretation of Copernicus.
In 1576, a startlingly
new picture
of the universe was printed.
Both in this diagram
and in his text,
Thomas Digges states
emphatically
that the universe is infinite.
He also shows the
planets confined --
he also shows the planets
confined in their spheres
as Copernicus had intended.
So he's correcting the
Copernican diagram.
He's correcting the De
revolutionibus by carefully
reading the text.
So in fact, this is the
first really accurate diagram
of what Copernicus was getting
at, apart from the fixed stars.
Digges' major intervention
concerns his interpretation
of what Copernicus says about
the size of the universe
and the possibility of
an infinite universe.
This woodcut appears in an
appendix to a new addition
of the popular almanac
by Thomas Digges' father,
Leonard called "A
Prognostication Everlasting"
which was based
on the traditional Ptolemaic
Earth-centered universe.
Thomas reprints his father's
work with a few corrections
and adds a perfect description
of the celestial orbs according
to the most ancient
doctrine of the Pythagoreans.
Lately revived by Copernicus
and by geometrical
demonstrations are proved.
And the free translation
with some additions of parts
of the first book of
De revolutionibus ,
it's the first English account
of the Copernican system
and the first publication of the
heliocentric diagram in Britain.
But with a hugely significant
addition of an infinity
of stars beyond the
solar system.
This was before Giordano Bruno's
more metaphysical speculations
on the infinite universe
which was possibly influenced
by Digges and was
published eight years later,
also in London in 1584.
Digges' work has recently been
discussed by David Wootton
in his well-received History
of the Scientific Revolution,
the Invention of Science .
According to Wootton, and I
quote, "The illustration spreads
over two pages and it
appears to have been added
as an afterthought as the
book went through the press.
Binders were never quite
sure what to do with it
to incorporate it as a foldout
page or as a two-page spread.
As you can see, the text of
the first part ends finis
so this is the end of Leonard
Digges' part of the book.
But the image has
[inaudible] or 43 printed
in the upper right corner of
the sheet in the last page
of the first part of the text
is obviously [inaudible] or 42.
So it's clearly intended
to be bound here
as an upright foldout.
As a frontispiece and
the kind of title page
to Thomas Digges'
Perfect Description
of the Celestial Orbs since
there's no other title page
to this part of the book.
Third, the bibliographical
analysis shows
that it cannot possibly
be an afterthought.
It is an integral part
of the book printed
along with the text.
I mention this as
a cautionary note.
Paying a little attention
to the physical object
might have saved Wootton
from his condescending
suggestion
that the illustration
was an afterthought.
And by implication, of less
importance than the text.
On the contrary,
it was carefully planned
from the beginning.
The woodcut would have
been an expense --
would have been expensive
to make
and printing it complicated
the production process.
So let's look at
it more closely.
The lettering within the outer
ring states that this orb
of stars fixed indefinitely
out extended itself
in altitudes spherically
and therefore immovable.
It is garnished with perpetual
shining glorious lights
innumerable far excelling
the sun both
in quantity and quality.
The striking thing about this
diagram and the reason it is
so often reproduced is that
the fixed stars are not
in the outer sphere
which only has text in it
but are outside it and at
variable distances from the sun.
In the text, Digges explains
that the stars are fainter,
the farther out they are,
until our sight is no longer
sharp enough to distinguish them
and the greatest
number are, as he says,
by reason of their wonderful
distance, invisible unto us.
I asked you to remember the
label on the outermost sphere
in the Copernican diagram,
the immovable sphere
of the fixed stars.
A central tenet of the
Copernican system is
that the Earth is not
stationary but spins
on its axis every 24 hours.
So when we see the heavens
wheeling over our heads,
they are not really moving.
We are. Copernicus could
not detect any paradox
in the fixed stars.
No measurable difference
in the angles
between the stars
wherever we are
on our annual journey
around the sun.
So the sphere of the fixed stars
must be at an immense distance
from the planetary spheres.
Copernicus only says that this
distance appears to be infinite,
appears to be infinite compared
with the tiny dot of the Earth.
Whether the universe outside
the fixed stars is infinite is
something that he,
Copernicus, said should be left
to the natural philosophers.
And historians have debated
whether Copernicus really
believed in an infinite
universe.
But the crucial thing is that
even if he did, he still meant
that the fixed stars are
contained in a spherical shell.
The astonishing new idea put
forward by Digges in his text
and in the image is that
there is no boundary
to the fixed stars.
They extend out to infinity.
The majority so far off that
they are invisible to us.
Another early English
Copernican, William Gilbert,
well-known for his pioneering
work on magnetism, wrote a work
on cosmology sometime in the
1580s but it was not published
until after his death.
This is "De mundo
nostro sublunari"
in which Gilbert made
clear that he believes
that the universe is
infinite and that the stars
and planets move
through a vacuum.
Gilbert distinguished
between light-giving stars
and reflecting bodies.
And it has been suggested
that this image demonstrates
Gilbert's belief
in multiple solar systems.
The largest stars
might indicate suns
and the smaller stars, planets.
But we have here to
be even more careful
about taking the
illustration to be an expression
of the author's ideas.
The woodcut is an accurate
representation of the diagram
in the manuscript which
survives in the British Library.
But it was compiled from
Gilbert's papers sometime
after his death in 1603.
We don't know if the diagram
is derived from something
that Gilbert drew or
if it was introduced
by his younger half-brother
when he assembled the text.
Whatever the source
of the diagram,
it is clearly influenced
by Digges.
And I think that
the largest stars
in this woodcut simply
represent brighter stars
and would refer --
therefore refer back
to the tradition begun
by Piccolomini in 1540,
as we saw earlier where the
different symbols represent
different magnitudes.
Having looked at the
maps of the heavens
up to Bayer's beautiful
[inaudible] of 1603
and then the movement of the
planets against the background
of the fixed stars, for the last
part of my talk, I want to look
at the book to put an
end to speculation,
if not to controversy.
In the words of the
great Galileo scholar,
Albert Van Helden,
after the publication
of Galileo's Sidereus
Nuncius in 1610, the universe
and the way in which it was
studied would never be the same.
The universe would
never be the same.
Sidereus Nuncius , the
"Starry Messenger" was decisive
because instead of debating
with ancient authority
and using complex
geometrical models,
Galileo used visual arguments.
He shows us what he
observed for the first time
with the telescope and argues
that this leads inevitably
to conclusions about the
nature of the universe.
Digges' speculation that
the more distant stars were
invisible to the naked eye
was excitedly confirmed
when Galileo first focused his
telescope on the fixed stars.
Referring to the classification
of the stars introduced
by Ptolemy, remember the first
magnitude is the brightest
and the sixth is the faintest,
Galileo writes, "With the glass,
you will detect below the
stars of the sixth magnitude
such a crowd of others
that escaped natural sight
that it is hardly believable.
For you may see more than six
further gradations of magnitude.
Here, Galileo shows part of
the constellation of Orion
on the left and the
Pleiades on the right.
The large open stars
are the ancient stars,
that is, the naked eye stars.
The new stars are solid black.
Of different sizes to
indicate different magnitudes.
The woodcut on the left shows
the three naked eye stars
in Orion's belt.
I'm sure you can see that.
So here's the belt and then
there are six in Orion's sword.
Surrounding them are 18 more
stars revealed by the telescope
and never seen before.
It's one of the many
puzzles about this book
that the woodcut is
too big for the page.
In this copy, the star
on the right is almost
full and into the gutter.
I'm not using fanciful
language here.
The gutter is the
bibliographer's term
for the inner margins
of the book.
Even in Galileo's
original drawing,
the page barely contains
the stars.
The printed woodcut follows the
finished drawing very closely
and the dimensions
are identical.
In many copies, one or more of
the stars at the top of the page
and one on the left are cropped
or trimmed away by the binder,
one of the reasons
that the Library
of Congress' untrimmed
copy which is on show
in the exhibition
is so important.
It might be argued that
this is a rhetorical device,
the unbounded page
becomes a metaphor
for the boundless,
infinite universe.
Whether or not this
was in Galileo's mind,
it could well have
had this resonance
for contemporary readers
as it does for us today.
Now the discovery of the vast
numbers of stars invisible
to the naked eye is only one
of the discoveries
reported in Galileo's book.
What made Galileo particularly
anxious to rush his book
into print was his discovery
of the satellites of Jupiter
which he dedicated to Cosimo
de Medici calling them the
Medician stars.
The satellites of Jupiter helps
to confirm the Copernican theory
by showing that the Earth was
not unique in the solar system
in having satellites or moons.
The -- excuse me --
the Sidereus Nuncius
is a news book
and Galileo could
easily have been scooped.
Third of the great
revolutions in the book
which actually comes first
is Galileo's discovery
of mountains on the moon.
This contradicted Aristotelian
orthodoxy that everything
in the heavens must be
perfect and unchanging
and the moon, a perfect sphere.
The impact of the printed
images is remarkable.
Nothing like this in
terms of either the medium
or the message had
been seen before.
There are four images,
one of which is repeated.
In the first image,
the new moon is shown
on the fourth or fifth day.
The terminator, the
division between light
and dark is not a smooth curved
line as seen with the naked eye.
But the telescope
reveals it to be jagged,
uneven, on a sinuous curve.
Several white spots are
seen in the dark areas.
And dark spots in
the bright areas.
The white spots gradually
enlarge and merge
with the bright areas
of the moon while more
appear in the dark part.
Galileo explains this by analogy
with terrestrial geography.
Only the peaks of mountains
are illuminated at sunrise
and the valleys are in shadow.
But the dark shadows diminish
as the sun climbs higher
until the whole valley
is flooded with light.
The first and third
quarters are shown here
to illustrate how
the shadows cast
by the sun define the huge
mountains around the large area
in the upper part of the moon.
Unlike the mountains,
the appearance
of the large ancient spots
on the moon, the ones seen
with the naked eye, do
not change as the angle
of illumination changes.
They might, following
the opinion
of Pythagoras [inaudible].
Here, the second image is
repeated and a fourth is added,
continuing the visual evidence
for the vast mountain
range in the upper area.
Now these are etchings,
intaglio plates printed
on a separate operation
from the text.
The text was printed first
by the letterpress printer using
a common press on the left,
in this contemporary
image, leaving blank spaces
for the illustrations.
The etchings were then
printed into these spaces
in a separate workshop
using the rolling press
which is quite a
different kind of press
which is shown on the right.
And as the caption to this
plate explains, this is a press
for printing images from
incised copper plates.
The plates are rather
clumsily printed
with a significant
amount of surface tone.
And there are ink
deposits on the plate edges
which have not been
well-cleaned before being put
to the rolling press.
So this -- so this is
sort of surface tone.
It hasn't been cleared off
and then there are some actual
ink deposits along here.
The lines and dots of
the image are created
by etching identified by
the fluidity of the lines
and the blunt ends
of the strokes viewed
under magnification.
The circular outline seems
to have been made with a pair
of compasses but
rather carelessly
as the lines have
doubled up in places.
There was little
conventional syntax of lines
or cross-hatching which we
would expect at this period.
Both the etching
and the printing
of the plates seem
amateurish in comparison
with what one would expect
of etching for this period.
For example, in the
contemporary,
by the contemporary Venetian
etcher Odoardo Fialetti.
Original watercolor
drawings by Galileo survive.
But they are not the direct
originals for the etchings.
Six moons are shown here and
a seventh is on another half
of the sheet numbered eight.
These finished drawings
are presumably based
on earlier sketches
as the field of view
of Galileo's telescope could
only take in at most half
of the moon's surface.
Galileo could never
have seen the whole disk
of the moon looking like this.
The four etchings in the
printed book are even further
from what was visible through
the telescope on any one night.
In the text, Galileo describes
observations of the surface
of the moon over
several nights but refers
in each case to the first image.
The etching is a composite
combining geographical features
of the lunar surface only
visible on different nights.
Even more extreme
is the appearance
of the large round crater in the
lower half of the moon's disk.
The crater on these two images
is derived from earlier sketches
of the crater alone and
drawn to a larger scale.
These are subsidiary figures.
Overlaying them on the main
image creates a completely
erroneous view of the moon.
The crater is nowhere near
this big but representing it
in this way allows
Galileo to argue his point
without introducing
another etching.
The four etchings are synthetic
images making a visual argument
in support of Galileo's
contention
that the changing appearance
of the moon surface as it waxes
and wanes are due to the shadows
cast by its physical features,
huge mountains, valleys, and
seas like those on Earth.
When the Sidereus Nuncius
was published in 1610,
the dominant form of book
illustration was engraving,
not etching.
With an established syntax
for representing the effects
of light on uneven surfaces,
the Sidereus Nuncius was the
messenger bringing the news
of Galileo's discoveries
to the public.
The etchings certainly
gave a sense of immediacy
to the printed pages
than the stiffer style
of engraving would have
done which the stiffer style
of engraving would
not have done.
The full scientific report
was intended to follow.
Writing to Cosimo de Medici
in the summer of 1611,
Galileo informed his patron,
"I want to draw the phases
of the moon for a whole period
with the utmost diligence
and imitate them
in minute detail.
And I want to have
them engraved in copper
by an excellent artist."
Galileo was well aware that his
images were not accurate maps
of the lunar surface and the
etchings was somewhat informal
for a scientific treatise.
For that, he needed a new
series of observations
and engravings made by a
professional printmaker.
In the event, Galileo next
turned his attention to sunspots
and it was Johannes
Hevelius who, in 1647,
published the first accurate
engravings of the moon surface
for a full lunation in
a spectacular series
of 20 engravings in
an imposing folio.
But that's another story.
So where does Galileo
leave us in 1610?
In 1603, the positions
of the fixed stars had
been accurately mapped
by Johann Bayer.
His beautiful atlas was on the
library tables of the wealthy
and it was also later used by
astronomers like John Flamsteed.
As Thomas Digges realized
and Galileo confirmed
with the telescope,
there were far more stars
than Bayer had recorded.
At greater and greater
distances,
stars are fainter and fainter.
There must, as Digges
pointed out, be many stars
which are simply too
faint for us to see.
Not only was the Earth no longer
the center of the universe
but the universe
itself had no end.
The Earth, as Copernicus
had explained,
was just another planet.
There are other planets like
ours, other solar systems.
Men in the moon,
extraterrestrial life,
such speculations were
not long in coming.
John Wilkins' Discovery of a
World in the Moone published
in 1638, is an account of the
new world, the new world view
of Copernicus, Kepler
and Galileo.
The Galileo moon -- Galilean
moon has Earth-like features
and says Wilkins
on the title page,
"Tis probable there may
be another habitable world
in that planet."
The image is a woodcut
with type set below it.
A very rare, it's a very rare
case of a title page designed
as a double page spread.
This is a very self-conscious
combination of text and image.
Again, it's no afterthought.
The makers of this book
put a lot of care into this
and we need to take
it seriously.
The woodcut is reproduced
as the top half
of the engraved title page
of the second enlarged
edition of Wilkins' book.
Below this, the figures of
Galileo on the left is copied
from the Latin edition
of Galileo's dialogue
on the two world systems
where the other figures
are Aristotle and Ptolemy.
Copernicus uncertain
and perplexed says,
"What if it is true?"
And Galileo gesturing to the
superior vision of the eagle
which his telescope had given
him says, "Here are his eyes."
And Kepler says, "And his
wings," hinting that to find
out more, we should fly
to the moon referring
to his science fiction dream,
Somnium , written in 1608
and published in 1634, a few
years before Wilkins' discovery.
The scroll on which the
title is written is a map
of the moon's surface.
The top half of the engraving
elaborating on the woodcut
in the first edition
is a wonderful example
of how much information can
be packed into a small space.
And this is only possible
with the fine lines
of engraving rather than the
coarser lines of woodcut.
What you see here on the screen
is less than four inches wide.
Here are the stars of different
magnitudes taken from Digges
but in the planetary system --
but in the planetary system,
the planets are on
orbital paths in space,
not confined to solid spheres.
The Earth is personified
as Ceres,
the goddess of agriculture.
With her, with actually
is with her sickle
and her sheaf of corn.
She is yearning for her
daughter, Proserpina,
personified as the moon.
Combining -- combined
with this is a lesson
in astronomy demonstrating how
the planets are lit by the sun
and the phases of the
moon as shown below.
This is a serious scientific
work, not mere science fiction
like William Godwin's Man
in the Moon which was
published in the same year.
So in conclusion, I hope that I
have shown, I have convinced you
that the printed book
shaped the universe.
The production of printed
images was not unproblematic
but the efforts made by
authors, editors and publishers
to put ideas into pictorial
form shows how important these
images were.
Copernicus' De revolutionibus
is a handsomely produced folio,
a worthy companion to books
of theology or philosophy.
Engraving allowed Bayer to
produce more accurate charts
and provide the opportunity
to present multiple layers
of allegory and science
in a book
for both connoisseurs
and astronomers.
High quality printing
and illustration helped
to sell these books and not
just to professional scientists.
These, in turn, helped
to bring the meaning
of the scientific findings
to a wide audience.
Images were necessary
for professional readers,
perhaps even more so for book
owners who were not going
to follow the science
too closely.
It is said that we live in
a visual age and I wonder
if images are significant
to scientific discovery
and communication
as they once were.
I'm looking forward to the
lectures on modern science
in this symposium to learn more.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lilla Vekerdy: Good morning.
My name is Lilla
Vekerdy and I am
from the Smithsonian Libraries
here to introduce Pedro Raposo.
Pedro Raposo is curator of
the Adler Webster Institute
for the History of Astronomy.
He holds a doctorate in
the history of science
from the University of Oxford.
He has published on topics such
as the history and heritage
of 19th century astronomy,
the history of colonial
observatories
and the circulation of knowledge
in 18th century Europe.
Raposo is responsible
for the use and research
of the Adler Planetarium's
varied collections
of historic scientific
instruments,
rare books and works on paper.
Sometime ago, I asked Dr. Raposo
when and why he decided to work
with heavenly objects.
He answered, "At the age of 18,
that is, a long, long time ago,
I founded a local astronomy
club with some friends.
We often went to
school associations,
festivities to show the moon
and other celestial objects
through a telescope to attendees
of all ages and walks of life.
I always liked to talk about
history topics in these events
such as Galileo, astronomy
and navigation in the age
of discoveries, the
discovery of the Uranus."
"I irrevocably became fascinated
with astronomy around 1993
when there was a lot of hype
about the Perseids
meteor shower.
Even though the shower was
not at least to the eyes
as a beginner observer in a
factory town in the suburbs
of Lisbon as spectacular as
the media promised it to be.
It made me look up and want
to identify the constellations
and learn more about
astronomy in general."
Dr. Raposo's talk is about
[inaudible] the heavens size,
scale and depth in
astronomical illustrations.
Dr. Raposo?
[ Applause ]
>> Pedro M.P. Raposo:
Good morning.
I would like to begin by to
thank well, Lilla Vekerdy
for this lovely introduction,
revealing my past
and my own romance
with astronomy.
You know, I also like to thank
the organizers of this workshop
for the invitation to be here.
I'm really thrilled to be
here among other reasons
because I am a historian
of science specializing
in the history with focus
on the history of astronomy,
who finds himself
working in an institution
which some 88 years now, has
been precisely in the business
of scientific visualization,
the Adler Planetarium in Chicago
which was the first optical
projection planetarium
in America.
And through our sky show,
through our exhibitions,
through our, for example,
space visualization laboratory
which is a part of the Adler
where you can go to daily
and see some really impressive
images and visualizations
and talk to an expert.
We've been trying
precisely to visualize
and to present the heavens
before our audiences.
I would like to share a brief
story with you, a recent story.
One of this is I was at one of
our neighbors, the Field Museum
which is in the Museum
Campus in Chicago.
And I met one of the volunteers
at the field museum, a lady who,
when I told her that I
worked, I was curator
at the Adler Planetarium,
she told me that, "Oh,
I don't really like
to go to the Adler."
Well, not a great
beginning of conversation
but then I asked her,
"So why is that?"
And she told me, "Well,
because it really reminds me
that the universe is immense.
The universe is overwhelming
and it makes me feel small."
Well then, I felt relieved.
Okay, we are doing
our job properly then
because all of that is true.
But in fact, imagining, more
than imagining the arrangements
of the spheres in the sky, the
arrangements of the planets
of the orbits, or imagine
the surfaces of other bodies,
thinking of the scale, the size
and thinking of space precisely
as space and our place in it,
is effectively challenged.
And what I would like to do over
the next 30 minutes or so is
to take you in a journey
through the Adler Planetarium
collections to see some examples
and to show you some examples
of how this three-dimensional
thinking in astronomy
and in cosmology expressed
itself through the centuries.
In the Middle Ages, one of
the most important tools
to teach astronomy was
the armillary sphere
which appears here in this
lovely manuscript fragment.
The armillary sphere represents
the central hearth as according
to Aristotle and Ptolemaic
universe surrounded
by the major astronomical
circles.
It is not exactly a physical
model of the universe but more
of a tool that helps think of
the centrality of the Earth
and of those astronomical
circles which are fundamental
to understand every other
motion and phenomena in the sky
as projected in the
celestial field.
But nonetheless, it did
convey the strong impression
of the place of the
Earth in the arrangement
and in the order of things.
In this frontispiece,
with French mathematician
Oronce Fine --
Oronce Fine appears
holding a [inaudible] light
in conversation with the muse
Urania and look that above him,
we see a complex diagram
in which the armillary sphere is
combined with a typical diagram
of the arrangement of the
orbs precisely to give this,
convey this idea that the
arrangement of the orbs
and the sphere all
converge in this idea
of how things are
arranged in the cosmos
and how motions can be
understood from the idea
of this relative arrangements.
Armillary spheres
sometimes were taken
to high degrees of complexity.
In this example from 1562,
by the prominent instrument
maker Gualterus Arsenius,
the armillary sphere includes a
substantial number of circles.
It's a very intricate
arrangement that has the purpose
of simulating different
motions of the heavens
and explain different
motions in the sky.
You see that it's a
very elaborate piece
and even the fact that it
survives [inaudible] suggest
that well, made by
a prominent maker
and such an exquisite piece,
more than a teaching tool
or more than a model of the
universe, it was also a symbol
of intellectual sophistication.
And we might guess
maybe of status
of the owner having the
universe and an object
that reproduced its
motions basically at hand.
Some paper engineering was
also used to try to make sense
of the complex, the complexity
of planetary orbits as presented
in the works of Ptolemy and then
has explained through the works
of other authors such
as Georg von Peurbach.
Here, we see a manuscript,
a [inaudible] manuscript
with volvelles illustrating
Peurbach's famous Theoricae
novae planetarium, the new
theories of the planets,
which was a work that had wider
circulation and was widely used
as a textbook in the 15th
and in the 16th centuries.
And what you see on
your left here --
so this is essentially a paper
device with movable parts
which would convey to
the user a better sense
of how the intricate arrangement
of circles and circular motions
that we heard of in the first
talk actually could explain
and help predict the position
of a planet in the sky.
But imagining the
specific arrangement
for each planet was
actually quite complicated.
Here we see this illustration
which is almost daunting,
really, where you see an attempt
of representing well on an image
on a [inaudible] image
the arrangements in space
of the specific arrangement
of orbs
and circles for each planet.
Some instrument makers undertook
the challenge of turning this
into a natural three-dimensional
object.
And what we're going to see
now in the image on your right,
it's very much resembling
of an armillary sphere
but it's actually
much more than that.
While the armillary sphere
was pretty much just the basic
representation of
the central Earth
and the major astronomical
circles --
that object on the right made
by Girolamo Della Volparia
in Florence, 1582, it's
actually a material realization
of the Ptolemaic theory
for the orbit of Mercury.
And you see all the
arrangement of circles
and how complex it was.
So these were all
techniques and ideas
that helped visualize the
complex arrangement of spheres
that was used to --
was necessary to explain the
celestial motions according
to Ptolemy and the
theories of Ptolemy.
Of course, they have -- with
the advent of the telescope
and of telescopic observation
and we have heard already,
we've heard substantially about
it in the first talk, of course,
that the use of visual evidence
and the use of visual arguments
to convey telescopic discoveries
and to inform debates
about what these findings
really meant in terms
of the order of things.
Of course, it brings
about new challenges
and opens new pathways
for visualization
and for representation.
And it's not only the
telescope, I think,
and it's not only
the printed image
that will help create really a
whole new image of the universe.
There was already a
background to accommodate all
of these new visual evidence.
Developments in perspective
throughout the Renaissance
[inaudible] new instruments
to measure the extensive mapping
now extending to the whole world
and refine old geographical
theories.
And also the development of
the mapping of the heavens
which is eloquently represented
on your right together
with the very mapping
of Earth in this image
from the famous Andreas
Cellarius atlas,
Harmonia Macrocosmica .
All of these provides
a background
in which visualization
of the universe,
of its and of the celestial
objects will reach new heights.
The old diagrams
showing the arrangements
of the orbs will
still be widely used
and they are still very
helpful to help situate
and to illustrate the different
arrangements that are central
to the debates of
the mid-17th century.
So here we see Ptolemy here.
This is the frontispiece of
Giovanni Battista Riccioli's
"Almagestum novum" from 1651.
And what we see here is pretty
much the visual synthesis
of mid-17th century astronomy.
You have here -- here, you
have Ptolemy basically assuming
that he was wrong and his
system here is pretty much
on the corner.
And you see that Astraea or
what seems to be some kind
of crossing between Astraea, the
goddess of justice and Urania,
the muse of astronomy -- she is
weighing two competing systems,
the system of Copernicus
and Riccioli's own version
of the system of Tycho Brahe
whose basic principle is
that you let the Earth
stay at the center
but you put the sun
orbiting the Earth
and then you can reason planets
orbiting the sun and in the case
of Riccioli's own system, two
planets still orbit the Earth.
And the trick was that
with a model like this,
you could still explain
and accommodate things
that you observed
with the telescope.
So she has, for example, the
phases of Venus and Mercury.
So there was no decisive
argument besides the issue
of stellar parallax which
was impossible to measure
at this point in history.
And that was already
mentioned in the first talk.
But there was no
decisive proof yet.
But what's really fascinating
here is that if you look
to the upper corners
of the frontispiece,
you see the planets
represented with features
that could be already
observed with the telescope.
Note, for example,
the bands in Jupiter
and the satellites
of Jupiter around it.
And here, a planet that is
very familiar and recognizable,
Saturn with its rings.
And Saturn was precisely one
of the bodies that boast one
of the major challenges
in terms of visualization.
The varying appearances
of Saturn as seen
through a telescope through
time was very intriguing.
So for decades, since
Galileo first observed it
with the telescope and
throughout the 1620s and 1630s,
it was very intriguing
to see Saturn showing sometimes
it had the appearance --
it seemed that it
had two satellites,
sometimes you could
see what astronomers
at the time called
[inaudible] or handles.
But it was difficult to figure
out what this really was.
It was Christiaan Huygens,
the author of the book
in which this illustration
appears,
the book called Systema
Saturnium published in 1659,
that came up with a
consistent explanation.
He used good telescopes that he
built himself which are now some
of the -- those telescopes are
now in the Boerhaave Museum
in Leiden in the Netherlands.
But he also made analogies
between the Earth-moon system.
He also discovered the first
satellite of Saturn, Titan.
And he also used some principles
from the mechanistic
philosophy of Rene Descartes.
So using all of these, but
above all, trying to figure
out the relative positions of
the Earth and Saturn in the sky
and imagining that
Saturn has a ring.
He comes up with what
is basically the correct
explanation in this very
striking illustration.
So what you see here,
so you have the sun
at the center, the Earth.
And then you have Saturn with
its ring and what the outer ring
of images actually shows to
you is how Saturn when seen
from the Earth with a
telescope in a certain position
and a certain relative
arrangement,
what is the impression that
it produces in the telescope?
And this image is quite
remarkable because it's not just
about explaining the
different positions
of the celestial bodies in
the sky but also an appeal
to reposition the observer.
So imagine what the
perspective of the observer is
and what the relative
disposition
of bodies in space are.
And so, this is really
remarkable and this is really
to a great extent, it's a
turning point in the way
of visualizing things in space.
Throughout the 18th century,
these objects, the orreries,
mechanical models of the solar
system in which you have --
well, a record of visual
mechanical representation
of the Copernican and now, of
course, of the Newtonian view
of the universe, of the planets
in their orbits around the sun.
Orreries are extremely important
in showing not just the
arrangement of the planets
but also showing the order
of the celestial
motions in the sky.
And there is a rich
iconography about the orrery,
this is probably one of the most
striking images of the orrery,
the famous painting
by Joseph Wright
which is [inaudible]
in an engraving.
And you can see those three
children and one philosopher
in the audience around the
orrery having this lively image
of things moving in space.
The Newtonian order
of the universe
which also carried a metaphor
of a moral order, of the harmony
of things, the harmony of the
heavens which was the same kind
of moral harmony
that we were supposed
to look for in our lives.
Perhaps most of the times
unsuccessfully but still --
still a powerful metaphor.
And even in the 19th century,
when the orrery, now competed
with many other technologies
of visualization,
the idea of the orrery as
something that provides a sort
of a key to the true
arrangements in motions
of planets in the sky
is still very strong.
Here on the left,
you see a plate
from Smith's Illustrated
Astronomy ,
sort of a visual textbook in
astronomy that was produced.
There were several editions
and I suppose it must have
been widely used in schools
in the U.S. And see, you look
here, the teacher is pointing
at a diagram, a flat diagram
of the orbits of the planets
and here, apparently
another teacher is pointing
at Saturn in the model.
And there's a figure
here which, of course,
very beautifully we imagine is
putting, cranking the orrery
and putting it in motion.
[Inaudible] that it can
make this connection
between the motions in the
model and the actual motions
in the sky and answer
the problem.
And that's a striking
image shows to you,
the image on the
right shows you.
You see Urania taking a young
lady who's looking at the orrery
and she's taking
her to the heavens
so the orrery is the very
key to the arrangements
and the order of the planets.
And the orrery is certainly
one of the ancestors
of my own institution,
the Adler Planetarium.
Here, we can see on the
left, you see the first model
of a project planetarium
from 1925 made
by the Carl Zeiss Company.
And there, you can
see model number two
which was the projector that was
set up at the Adler Planetarium
in 1930 and which again, was the
first of its kind in America.
It's important to remember
that even though
originally the planetarium,
the planetarium projector
was meant
to reproduce what
we can actually see
in the sky outdoors in the dome.
Basically, it brought
the heavens indoors.
But in the origins of the
orrery was the intention
to create a connection as an
experience between what you see
in the actual sky and what
the actual arrangement
of the planets in space are.
So the concept of the projection
planetarium was originally
developed intended
as a counterpart
to a Copernican orrery.
So and the projector,
the planetarium projector was
originally called the Ptolemaic
planetarium precisely
because it brings us back
to the geocentric perspective.
And so the very idea
in the beginning was
to create this connection
between that geocentric
perspective
and the actual arrangements
of the orbits of the planets
in the sky and you see that in
this Copernican planetarium.
You have a moving platform and
there's a gentleman here looking
for some kind of periscope.
And is looking at the
orrery in the ceiling.
And supposedly what he's seeing
in through the periscope is
how the planets would appear
in profile in the actual sky.
Now, one of the things
that planetariums and all
of these models could not
convey efficiently was the idea
of the true size,
the true dimensions
of both the planets
and their orbits.
And this has always been
a very important question.
So in the 17th century, debates
about the sizes of stars,
for example, were extremely
important in discussions
about the actual
cosmological arrangement.
Was Tycho right?
Was Copernicus right?
And the sizes of the stars
together with the debates
about it being possible or
not to determine the parallax
of stars, this was
extremely important
in the cosmological
debates of the periods.
Here we see going back
to Andreas Cellarius'
Harmonia Macrocosmica ,
here we have again a very
striking illustration
which pretty much I won't dare
say it was the first of its kind
but sets up a visual convention
that will be extensively used
in the following centers
to show relative sizes
and dimensions of
celestial bodies.
So basically, what this
image does is to superimpose
in a single representation
bodies of different sizes
as they were derived on the
basis of Ptolemy's theory.
So basically, you
have the moon here.
You have a scale here
which is marked in --
sorry, you have the Earth here.
So this is the Earth.
And so basically, the diameter
of the Earth is the
unit, the basic unit.
And then you have
several bodies.
You have the planets
and you also have stars
that were supposedly of
different sizes according
to their brightness which is
a conception that, of course,
we know now that
it's not correct
but that's not the point.
This is a very powerful way of
representing the different sizes
of celestial bodies by
showing their proportional
relative sizes.
It's Christiaan Huygens again
who apparently is among the
first to use the same kind
of convention [inaudible]
to convey the idea
of the planets according
to the Copernican system.
So in his Kosmotheorus which
was published posthumously
and which is work in which
Huygens very much speculates
about the possibility
of life existing
in the other planets
based on the principle
that the other planets again,
must be pretty much
like the Earth.
They simply, they are different
in size and in appearance
but they must be the same thing.
So they must have
their own inhabitants.
And of course, with
developments in telescopes
and in the growing use of the
telescope as a measuring device,
a better knowledge --
sorry, a better knowledge
of planetary diameters
and the dimensions
of the planets now allows
Huygens to create his model
in which he represents the sun
and then he can show the
relative sizes of the planets
as compared to that of the sun.
And of course, you see here
that the internal planets, Mars,
the Earth, Venus and --
Mercury, Venus, the Earth
and Mars are very, very small.
But again, for Huygens, it was
essentially a matter of size
and appearance because
he considered
that all planets
potentially could have their
own inhabitants.
The same kind of
convention then will appear
in different types
of publications.
For example, in broadsides
which were popular publications
that were aimed at a
variety of audiences,
here we have a broadside
on the left.
We have a broadside
by William Whiston,
A Scheme of the Solar System
from around 1720 and you see
that this is meant to represent
the arrangements of the orbits
of the planets, also in there
with their relative sizes.
And then you see
that's superimposed
to this illustration which
also shows you the orbits
of the comets, you
also have this diagram
that again shows the relative
dimensions of the planets.
Same thing here in
this illustration
from 1763 from the Netherlands.
And some authors will add
further visual strategies
to convey further, convey this
idea of distances, of sizes
and importantly, to
make the observer
and the reader reposition
herself
or himself in other worlds.
So here in this plate
from Astronomy Explained upon
Sir Isaac Newton's Principles
Mwhich was an extremely
important book and plenty
of editions throughout the 18th
century, very important book
in the popularization
of the ideas of Newton,
James Ferguson was himself a
very keen popularizer and maker
of scientific instruments.
And you see that here, you
have very much the same kind
of conventions showing the
relative dimensions of orbits,
showing the different
sizes of the planets
in proportion to each other.
But here, this is a
remarkable addition.
What you see here is basically
the apparent size of the sun
as seen from the
different planets beginning
with from Mercury to -- this
one goes from Mercury to Saturn.
And this is remarkable
because this is not just
about showing different sizes
or showing different dimensions
but again, appealing to the
observer and to the reader to go
to different locations and
imagine how things would be seen
from different locations.
Here in this illustration
from A Compendious System
of Astronomy by
Margaret Bryan,
we see very much the
same kind of conventions.
And it's interesting to note
that these visual strategies
will appear throughout a large
number of different
publications in which the image
of the solar system
itself, it's changing.
Notice here, for
example, "Georgium Sidus"
which eventually was
renamed as Uranus.
So this diagram already shows a
new planet that has been added
to the inventory of
the known planets.
And the more things
were discovered
and during the first
half of the 19th century,
several asteroids
were discovered
and they were generally
considered as planets, at least,
as long as you could still
include them in the model
of the solar system, you
could still call them planets.
By the mid-19th century,
perhaps around 10 were known.
By the late, by the end of the
19th century, 500 were known
and so eventually, they
had to be reclassified
as a group of their own.
But before of that, they were
entitled to their own presence
in diagrams of the solar system.
And here, you see
again from Asa Smith,
here you see a diagram
showing the sizes
of the planets including
the asteroids.
And here is a very
interesting diagram
which shows the relative
inclinations of the orbits
of the planets in the solar
system, a very intricate image
because it also includes
the asteroids.
This was a period when
there was a growing market
and a growing demand for
this kind of publication.
There's a growing middle class.
There's a growing
access to education.
And of course, instrument
makers and printers try
to take advantage of
these new market niches.
This was also a period when
the techniques of projection
and the Magic Lantern was
widely used in public lectures
and widely used to convey
ideas about astronomy
and other fields to
general audiences.
Here we see a rather
remarkable example
of how these visual [inaudible]
to convey the different sizes
of the planets and
the different --
and the distances and sizes of
their orbits appears in a set
of transparencies
which how the idea is
that he would hold the
transparency against the source
of light and he -- and this,
the image here would
gain vivid color.
So it was in a sense bringing
the techniques of projection
and the magic -- the
effect of the Magic Lantern
to a small group,
a small audience
and maybe more even a
domestic environment.
This form of visual
representation is very enduring.
We still use it nowadays
everywhere in planetaria
and in science museums
all over the world.
This is a gallery at
the Adler planetarium.
And here, you have the
planets of the solar system,
the Solar System Gallery.
And we basically have the
planets at their relative sizes
and here, you can see this is
the top of one of our theaters.
And so that stands for the sun
and these are the relative
sizes of the planets.
This is very much reminiscence.
You will see this kind of
thing in science museums
and planetaria all
over the world.
And this is very reminiscent
of the visual conventions
and the strategies
that we just saw
in those publications
and illustrations.
Now, we always have
to challenge that.
If you want to combine
the scale of the planets
with the actual scale of
the orbits, in that case,
it helps if you use a whole
city because the scale is
so overwhelming that we cannot
really combine it efficiently
within a planetarium.
So this is again, this
is a kind of installation
that you will also see in
different science sites
and science museums and
planetaria all over the world.
So we did at the
Adler Planetarium,
we've been using 2015 and
so the idea is that in order
to [inaudible] the scale
of the solar system,
we would have the sun basically
at the door of the planetarium
and then we will have the orbits
of the planets extending
throughout the city.
So it will be a 10-minute walk
to Mars which would be right
by the Field Museum
and the Shedd Aquarium.
But if you want to reach
Pluto, and of course,
we have to include Pluto,
not to hurt anyone's feelings
[laughter], you would have
to go almost to Evanston to
the very limits of the city.
So you would have the
super-imposition of well,
the scale of the solar system
with the scale of the city
which is a kind of
[inaudible] that they use
to basically create the
sense of familiarity with all
of these overwhelming scales.
And I think the word
familiarity,
it's very important here.
But still, I think
nothing is compare --
when we deal with scales and
sizes, we're still dealing
at the very geometrical
and abstract level.
I think nothing is more
compelling than natural,
actually thinking of the
planets as actual places.
And I think this sense of place,
it's pretty much what is --
it underlies the space age
really because you don't,
you don't send spacecraft
to moving dots in the sky.
You send spacecraft to
places where you would expect
to find some kind of
landscape topography features.
Of course, the telescope
gave faces
and features to the planets.
And I find these plates
from Alain Mallet,
this Description de l'Univers
from 1686, very striking
because clearly, he
doesn't respect the scale
and he presents the planets just
against these bucolic
landscapes.
But I think the fact that
he doesn't respect scale,
he wants certainly to create
a compelling visual effect
and I think there is some, there
is some kind of statement here
that the planets have --
are also part of our
cosmic landscape in a sense.
And they have their own
features, their own landscapes
and their own spatiality
as things here on Earth.
Of course, we heard about how
the moon and how the discoveries
in the moon excited
the imagination,
the early modern imagination
and excited ideas about again,
repositioning the observers, the
idea of traveling to the moon.
The moon was, in fact, extremely
important because it's the --
well, it's the closest
celestial body
that we could actually map early
in the history of the telescope.
So astronomers like
Hevelius and others
in the 17th century produced
the first atlases of the moon.
In many cases, using resorting
to conventions that were used
in terrestrial photography and
even trying to use the same kind
of nomenclature which
eventually gave way
to a nomenclature more based
on the names of astronomers
and scientists connected to
the moon, which of course,
is sort of a self-reference
[inaudible]
for astronomers themselves.
But the fact is that these
moons really created this idea
of a celestial body being
the celestial body becoming a
cartographic object,
becoming a natural place.
And throughout [inaudible]
the 19th century,
even before photography
entered into the picture,
we have very detailed maps of
the moon such as this chart
of the moon with 25
plates by Julius Schmidt
which really gives a very
strong topographic impression
and image of the moon.
But more than that, this
is still a representation
on a sheet of paper.
Julius Schmidt himself got
involved in giving a sort
of a volumetric existence to
the moon by becoming involved
in the making of
this moon globe.
A very impressive moon globe
that was made in Germany
under the coordination and the
supervision of Julius Schmidt
and which eventually came to
the United States in the 1890s
and was put on display as shown
in this photograph at what,
at what at the time,
it was called the
Field Columbian Museum.
However, we know that there
are newspaper articles
so before the globe was put on
display at the Field Museum,
it was used as a kind
of a traveling exhibit.
And it seems that it
was not very successful
because people didn't
really seem to engage
with it which is interesting.
Could it be because it
basically just presented them
with a very barren moon
and that was an exception?
I think -- I find it
actually much more striking
than these moon globes with its
three-dimensionality is the idea
of again, the moon
having its own landscapes,
being its own place.
Here we have an extremely
interesting use of photography,
not to photograph the moon
itself because when this book,
The Moon Considered
as a Planet, a World,
and a Satellite
by James Nasmyth
and James Carpenter
was published,
actually the first
edition is from 1874.
Photography was not still --
astronomical photography
was not developed enough
to make an accurate
mapping of the moon.
But so Nasmyth used, made
plaster models of lunar craters
and had to imagine some
lunar features to look
like to create these
really, really impressive
and striking images that
made us imagine, I think,
made the reader imagine
herself as being in the moon.
Although Nasmyth advised
that it's probably not
a very good place to be
and not a very suitable
place for life.
But still, this idea of
the moon, of a landscape
in another body, I
think, it's very striking.
And nothing contributed as much
to that, I guess, as the debates
around the supposed
canals of Mars.
Here we see an image of Mars
with its supposed canals
from 1908 or the appearance of
Mars in 1905 by Percival Lowell.
So many of you know Percival
Lowell became fascinated
with the idea that there
could be canals on Mars.
And it was announced
by an Italian astronomer
called Giovanni Schiaparelli.
He talked about canal
in Italian.
It was translated as canals
and it conveyed the impression
that perhaps those were
artificial structures made
by some kind of Martian
civilization.
So here, we move from not only
Mars becomes a cartographic
object but it becomes even
almost like an arena space
for infrastructure
public works program
which is quite impressive.
And needless to say, what's
happening in all of these images
and ideas is very much a
straightforward projection
of things that are
happening in Earth.
All of this is happening
in an age of empire,
an age of great infrastructural
projects,
an age of extensive
cartographic imperial projects.
And so, the Martian canals are
very much a resonance in this.
But they have a tremendous
effect in public imagination.
For example, here we move
from the map of the planet
with its supposed canals which
was just basically an effect
of the brain trying to
connect disparate features
and this was proved
in the 1940s,
there were no canals
in Mars whatsoever.
But Pandora's Box
had been opened.
So the [inaudible], public
imagination will remain excited
about Mars to this day.
There is something, I guess,
that connects Elon Musk
to what was happening
in this period,
this fascination with Mars.
And of course, space
artist Chesley Bonestell,
[inaudible] too but
in the United States,
Chesley Bonestell -- they
played a very important role
in further exciting
the public imagination
by depicting the planets,
combining available scientific
information with well,
a great leap of imagination.
And of course, Bonestell before
becoming a fulltime space
artist, he had worked as a
matte painter in Hollywood.
So he was well acquainted
with perspective and shadow.
And of course, he used
all of those techniques
to create his very impressive
and realistic planetary
landscapes.
Here on Mars and here again, the
idea of relocating the observer.
Mars, as it would be seen
from its larger satellite.
And here, the famous painting
set on a scene from Titan.
And Chesley Bonestell went even
further down the solar system
and he even invited us
to position ourselves
in other planets orbiting other
stars which is very impressive.
Now imagining, we've
been talking essentially
of the solar system.
And now, I move to the
final part of my talk.
Imagine the solar system,
imagine this through scale
and its true dimensions
and getting the sense
of place was difficult enough
but more so was to imagine
to depict and to represent
the stellar heavens.
Of course, we had the debates
and the rise of Copernicanism
in the 17th century excited the
imagination of several authors
and thinkers about
the possibility of
or what was called the
plurality of worlds,
the idea of other stars.
So if the Earth is just a planet
orbiting the sun, it is possible
that other stars have their
own planetary systems as shown
in this theatrical frontispiece
of Fontenelle's Dialogues
on the Plurality of Worlds .
And here again, we see the same
idea in display by Nicolas Bion,
in this case meant to illustrate
the ideas of Rene Descartes
and this idea that
matter created vortices
that kept things in motion.
But interestingly, it's how --
so we have the depiction
of the solar system here
and then the solar system is
just another star among other
stars with their own
planetary systems.
Eventually the ideas of
Descartes are overthrown
by Newton and Newtonian
mechanics.
And in this very
dramatic representation
of the Newtonian universe, which
interestingly was made by a man,
Issac Frost, who was part of the
Muggletonian sect so he wanted
with this image to show
this system is wrong
and is not compatible
with the bible.
However, it produced one of
the [inaudible] most beautiful
and striking representations
of the Newtonian idea
that stars are uniformly
distributed in space.
And of course, here, the element
that maybe stars have their
very own planetary systems.
And note the colors
which are very impressive
so this was a technique,
an early printing
technique developed
by George Baxter using
different woodcuts
and colors producing
this striking effect.
But now, even those
images convey this idea
of the immensity of the universe
and the stellar universe.
They don't really tell us much
about how are stars
actually arranged in the sky?
And more importantly, a question
that was [inaudible] question
and not that many people
there to address at least
up to the 18th century, what
is that white swath that we see
across the sky, the Milky Way?
Of course, that Galileo
and others knew
when they pointed
their telescopes,
they knew they were
essentially stars
but why is there a concentration
of stars in that direction?
One of the first authors
that not only speculates
about the shape of the
Milky Way and that this --
but also of the distribution
of stars is Thomas Wright.
Thomas Wright was essentially
a teacher so he had many hats.
So he was essentially a teacher
but he was also a surveyor
and an architect who had
learned astronomy essentially
by himself.
And Thomas Wright's
project was not just
to apprehend the structure
of the Milky Way but in fact,
his major concern was to combine
the idea of a distribution
of stars in the universe and
their order in the universe
with the moral and divine
center of the order of things.
So Wright essentially
speculates about the structure
and distribution of stars.
But he has one correct intuition
which is that if we see
so many stars and this is
basically what is meant,
what this plate is
meant to show.
If you are here and if
you look in a direction
where most stars are
concentrated, so of course,
you will see a swath of
stars in the white swath
in that direction in the sky.
But now, what is the
actual arrangement of stars
and what's our place in it
that produces this effect?
Wright plays with
different concepts.
So one of the concepts
he comes up with is
that maybe the stars
are arranged in a sort
of a sphere forming a kind of a
hollow globe and in the center
of that globe, so here are
the stars and in the center
of that globe is
the very divine,
the center of divine
providence and the moral
and divine center
of the universe.
And if we are positioned here,
if our sun is positioned
somewhere around here, so again,
when we look in the tangential
direction to the sphere
of stars, we will an effect
like the Milky Way in the sky.
Wright was not using
observational evidence.
So he was basically
speculating and he played
with other possible
arrangements as well.
So here in the analogy
of Saturn,
he imagined how the stars
could create the appearance
to an observer on Earth, if
they were distributed in rings
around a center which is here
as the appearance of the planet
but precisely just to emphasize
this idea of a metaphor.
And even though Wright was
not very fond of the idea
of multiple centers in the
universe, he also played
with that hypothesis and this
is what this image actually
shows you.
And now, I would
like to show you
to better help us visualize
how this would work in space.
I would like to show you a
brief animation made by some
of my colleagues at the Adler
Planetarium based on Wright's.
So this an animation made by
my colleague, Mark Subbarao,
who's the director of our
Space Visualization Laboratory
and Julieta Aguilera, who's
no longer with the Adler
but also worked in the Space
Visualization Laboratory.
So here, we have original
Wright's illustration.
So this is how the
stars would look
like according to
that model of his.
And now, we will soon
get into, precisely get
into a tangential plane
for the sphere of the stars
and get this impression
in space.
But of course, again, these
conceptions, these of course,
don't really have --
don't really explain what
we actually are observing
in the sky.
It had the merit of trying to
bring and trying to materialize
and to create a spatial
thinking about the arrangements
of stars in the universe.
But the connection between
actual astronomical observation
and the attempt to study the
structure of the galaxy came
with William Herschel.
So William Herschel, who is
better known for his discovery
of Uranus, his major project,
one of his major projects
in astronomy was try to figure
out the structure of the galaxy.
And he carried about him
extensive observing program
using large telescopes
that he made himself
and used some sort
of proto-statistics.
So basically, he made
several assumptions
which now we know
are not correct.
But he basically assumed
that he could see the borders
of the galaxy.
And so, he began by
pointing a telescope
to different directions
in the sky
and by counting how many stars
he could see in each direction.
And so, by using that data, he
established this first attempt
of a model of the galaxy.
And again, I can show
you another animation.
So basically what we have
here, and you have the Earth
at the center and you
have most of the stars
in the Milky Way concentrated
along a single plane.
And even though, of course,
the actual model of the galaxy
as according to the astronomy
of today is much different,
the basic intuition that the
stars must be distributed along
the same plane is
basically correct.
And now, I would like to --
I'd like to show you
another animation.
So here, we have it again.
It's basically again
the intuition
that the stars are more or
less distributed along the
same plane.
And of course, that the idea
of a spiral galaxy
comes much later.
And I will actually end my talk
with that in a few minutes.
So here, we have --
so basically, from the
illustration made by Herschel,
we turned that into the
actual distribution of stars.
And here is the production of
the effect of the Milky Way
so when you're looking precisely
in the direction of the plane
where most of the
stars are concentrated.
It was only in the 20th
century, even though it's
such a familiar image, it
was only in the 20th century
that astronomers were finally
able to prove that the shape
of the galaxy is
actually a spiral shape.
And what you see here is one of
two models, actual models made
by William Morgan who was
at the Yerkes Observatory.
And so he basically, by studying
the distribution of stars
and clouds of gas, whose
positions are represented
by this tiny cotton spheres, it
was already known that old stars
in spiral galaxies tend to
be concentrated at the center
of the galaxy and then you have
the younger stars, blue stars
and you have ionized gas in
the outer arms of the galaxies.
And so when Morgan and
his collaborators tried
to map some clusters of the
young stars and ionized gas,
they found these positions
and what you see here
and this was presented
at the meeting
of the American Astronomical
Society in 1951
and Morgan had gotten
a standing ovation
when he presented
this very model,
that materialized what he had --
what he had derived
from his data.
So this is pretty much
where the first time
where you can see more or
less, the spiral shapes
of the galaxy being
derived and being presented
which is now a very
familiar shape.
So familiar that we even
have it in our backyard,
in the Adler Planetarium.
So what you see here on the left
is a model, a sculpture inspired
on the spiral shape of
galaxy by Johan Dave Mooney.
He replaced the gas with
the skyline of Chicago.
And this is kind of our own
local Stonehenge in a sense.
So you could call
it the Adlerhenge.
So basically it's a
monument, it's a sculpture
with several stones with
astronomical alignments
but again, based on the
shape of the galaxy.
So that pretty much that shape
that was first derived using
that model is now pretty much a
very familiar image in astronomy
to the point that it's even
used in artistic installations
around the planetarium.
I like very much the fact
that this sculpture is just
by the lake which serves
in a sense as a reminder
that our galaxy is actually just
part of a much broader horizon.
But by creating familiar
shapes and familiar forms
and by somehow making
the heavens tangible,
giving them dimensions,
bringing them closer to us,
super-imposing the scale
of the heavens with scales
of things we are more familiar
with like the scale of a city,
and essentially trying
to present them in a way
that gives a sense of place,
I think we make the heavens
more familiar and apprehensible.
And I would like to end by
saying that and going back
to the story I told
in the beginning
about that lady was overwhelmed
by the scale of the universe,
I think imagining the
extraordinary is essentially an
attempt to make it ordinary,
apprehensible and familiar.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Stillo: All right,
thank you very much, Pedro.
It is my true pleasure to
welcome Kimberly Arcand,
our next speaker and our last
for this session to the stage.
Kimberly is the visualization
lead
at NASA's Chandra
X-ray Observatory
which has its headquarters
at the Smithsonian
Astrophysical Observatory
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Arcand is an award-winning
producer and director.
And she is a leading expert
in studying the perception
and comprehension of high
energy data visualization
across the novice
expert spectrum.
As a science data storyteller,
she combines her background
in molecular biology
and computer science
with her current work in the
fields of astronomy and physics.
Today, Kimberly will be
talking about the intersection
of data visualization
and human choice
which is a sort of
fascinating topic.
On a personal note, it
was with some timidity
that I first approached
Kimberly for this symposium.
I was aware of her intimidating
amount of publications,
her work with NASA and her
TED talks but I imagine
that she would have
little interest in talking
to a rare books curator
about her research.
One can fake many things
but knowledge of physics
and molecular biology
was beyond my capability.
I was happily proven wrong and
Kimberly is here with us today.
Her enthusiasm and
dedication to stories
about science is truly
inspiring and so I am so pleased
to welcome Kimberly
to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Kimberly Arcand:
Thank you so much.
I have an artifact and I'm
going to put it on display.
I'm like a proper curator.
So I'm going to talk about
things that are very big
and also things that
are very small.
And the reason I'm
going to do that is
because I started out with this.
This is Ixodes scapularis.
It is essentially a deer tick.
And inside its stomach are
these little tiny spirochetes,
these bacteria that
when transmitted
to humans can give us Lyme
disease if the tick is attached
to you for like 24 to
48 hours but details.
The point is this is
where I started out.
This was kind of my introduction
into science as an
undergraduate.
But I quickly realized that I
was actually more interested
in the tools that I was using,
the computer essentially
than I was interested in
staring at the stomach
of the deer tick 24 hours
a day under a microscope.
So I went and studied
data visualization
and image and meaning.
And that actually
landed me a job working
for NASA's Chandra
X-ray Observatory.
Now, I got this job
when I was --
let me see, it must
have been 1998
so it's been almost 20 years.
The Chandra X-ray Observatory
was just about to launch.
And it's an amazing
technological achievement.
It studies the high
energy universe so things
like exploding stars, black
holes, colliding galaxies --
these really violent
cosmic events
that we can study high
energy information from.
It was great to be a part
of that as it was launching.
But again, this is where
I was starting out.
This is actually an image
of the spirochete
inside that tick stomach.
It's Borrelia burgdorferi.
And this each -- one of these
little spiral things is about 10
to 25 micrometers long.
So I had to translate that
information that I was used
to dealing with into looking
at things like this instead.
This is the [Inaudible]
galaxies.
It's a sort of spiral-shaped
collision of two galaxies.
And this is 60,000
light years across.
Where a light year is the
distance that light travels
in a year which is about
10 trillion kilometers.
So 60,000 times 10
trillion kilometers.
So it's a pretty big
scale difference, I think.
But really, what I want to talk
about today is this idea and I'm
so happy that the
historians went before me
because I'm not a historian.
So it's great that that language
has already been introduced
and I can just ride
on their coattails.
Because I want to talk about
this idea of a visual language
which both speakers earlier
talked about briefly.
And they also introduced
Galileo's moon
which I will show too.
But I won't have
to talk about all
because you're all
experts obviously
in Galileo's moon by now.
So when we talk about
how our images
of the universe are really how
any image in science is created.
It's through a selection
of choices.
It's through a human using
software that has been created
by humans using data that
was collected by hardware
that was made by humans.
So there are these
strings of choices
and human biases along the way.
I'm going to try to
talk about some of that.
So to make images like this,
there's this visual language
scale, context, dimensionality,
field of view, cropping,
selection itself.
These things are done
to make a point, right.
There is a science story to
tell but there's also this idea
that you want your image to be
memorable, to be persuasive.
So we're going to look at
bugs because obviously,
I love bugs if I spent so
much time looking at them.
These are from Hooke's
Micrografia who we also heard
about from, I think, both
-- no, Gaskell mostly.
And we've got a couple
of examples here
that I particularly like.
One, I just think
they're beautiful.
These are really
beautiful illustrations.
Hooke, I think, had a really
amazing talent for being able
to bring his objects to life.
But he's also using very
specific visual techniques
to translate something that
started out in three dimensions
into a two-dimensional form.
He's collapsing that
information onto a version
that works on the page.
And he's carefully
creating his images through,
you guessed it, a
series of choices.
So in this case, Hooke is
really placing his instrument,
a microscope typically but he
did also work with telescopes
as an extension of our senses.
With this introduction of this
new equipment in the 1600s,
it offered that the observer
could then function as a bridge,
a bridge between
an invisible world
and in other interested parties
who didn't necessarily have
to do the observing themselves.
That immediately gives you
a sense of distance already
as the third party viewer,
not just the distance
physically but also in time.
So what kind of visual
strategies did Hooke use?
Well, he used his
space really well.
Isolation, composition,
contrast, shading,
dimensionality, all these
really important things
that we use today, hundreds
of years later in astronomy.
So a really quick description
of what it is we're looking at.
On the left, we've
got a lovely gnat.
And this beautiful gnat has
been zoomed in quite a bit
so that you don't
see all of its body.
That's a very intentional
framing.
It's just enough so you can
see the details of the wings,
of the body on the
bottom, of just the hairs
on its legs, really lovely.
On the right, we actually
have the eye of a drone fly.
I think it's a grey
drone fly, to be precise.
And again, with this
image, we're cropped
in really, really tight.
Hooke is taking you to a very
specific place really guiding
your eye on what to see
and what's important.
There's a really
interesting perspective here
on what he is choosing to do.
So this sort of visual
language then has
to be essentially
decoded, right.
By the cropping, by the framing,
he's giving you a very specific
but also very dramatic and quite
beautiful thing to look at.
He was always one for drama.
So how do we compare
with astronomy?
And I had a little
fun here because both
of these nebulas are
named, nicknamed after bugs.
So on the left, we have the
Ant Nebula because why not?
But you can see, here I chose
to crop in pretty tightly.
This is using optical
or visible data
from the Hubble Space Telescope.
And what a planetary
nebula like this is,
is essentially a sun-like
star that is slowly dying.
As they die, they puff
off their outer layers
and create these beautiful
nebulas that you see here.
Now, in both of these examples,
they're really nice
with their symmetry.
So I also picked that on
purpose besides the fact
that they were named after bugs.
And I've cropped in really
tightly for a reason.
So there is more
data to see here
but I'm not allowing
you to see it.
The cropping is a
very specific intent.
You want to see all of the
action, all of the things
that are going on as this
sun-like star is throwing off
its outer shell.
And then, of course,
on the right,
that one's called
the Bug Nebula.
It's also nicknamed the
Butterfly Nebula but I'm going
to use bugs since it's
closer to the previous slide.
And it's the same thing.
It's the same type
of planetary nebula.
This beautiful death of a star
and we're cropped in so tight
because right inside
the center point
of that bipolarization is the
star itself that we can't see
because in this case,
we're using optical light.
And optical light cannot get
through that gas and dust.
So again, very intentional.
Now, we're going to look at
rosemary and other leaves,
not as exciting as a topic
but what I really liked is
that the scope view provides a
sort of secondhand experience
that makes it feel more virtual
like you're actually there.
You're actually looking
through the microscope yourself.
Of course, by doing
this, you get to tie
in really close again.
You get to look at this texture.
You get to look at how he's
done the shading in the area
that he selected of interest.
But it's also again
quite intentional.
And in astronomy, we
can do similar things.
So here, I picked these images
because well, they're round
and I thought the symmetry
was nice for the texture.
But essentially, we're looking
at three examples
of exploded stars.
So these are stars
larger than our sun
that have, you guessed it, died.
And I'm not like really
morbid but it's just --
this is, you know, the nature
of the universe in some sense.
So we're going to be talking
about a lot of dead stars today.
But again, what this really
tight closed circular crop
allows us to do is to
see a lot of the detail
and also it's a practical thing
because in all three examples
of these super nova remnants,
all the data was taken
by the Chandra X-ray
Observatory.
Outside of those frames,
there's not really much to see.
It's just kind of black space
and a little bit of x-ray noise.
So if you leave an
entire frame like that
around this important x-ray
observation, it gives a sense
to the viewer that there is
nothing else around that object.
And that's actually not true.
It's just we can only
see this in x-ray light.
If we were to combine it
with say, an optical field
or infrared, we would see yet
more of the universe behind it.
So by cropping in really
closely to the objects,
we're actually helping to view,
to help guide the viewpoint
that these are specific objects
that we're just concentrating
on right here.
Now, not bugs but
looking at seeds.
Why I selected these images
from Hooke's drawings was
that I just thought the texture
and the dimensionality
were really exquisite.
On the left, we have
poppy seeds.
So this magnification
is really quite amazing.
And on the right, we have
seeds of thyme, I believe.
Now, you can see all the
little mottling, the texturing,
the ridging, you can see
where his light is coming
from because it's
casting shadows.
And that kind of dimensionality
again makes it feel more real
as if you're closer to the
observation, to the information,
to the data than you
might be otherwise.
In astronomy, dimensionality
is incredibly important too.
Now, this image, I just selected
because it kind of looked
like the seeds in a way.
But again, you're looking
at individual galaxies
that are many, many
billions of light years away.
A light year is the distance
that light travels in a year,
10, you know, trillion
kilometers.
So these are billions
upon billions.
This is pretty much as far as
we can see in astronomy today
in the observable universe.
And still when we're talking our
image, when we're creating them,
we are trying to make
sure that the idea
of dimensionality
is still there.
But probably an even better
example is this image which is,
I think, kind of famous.
It's from the Hubble
Space Telescope.
It's called the "Pillars
of Creation"
and it's also nicknamed
the Eagle Nebula and M-16.
Astronomy has a thing for names.
We've got a lot of nicknames.
But these are really beautiful,
tall columns of gas and dust
where stars are being born.
So there's -- so there we go.
It's not all about death.
The column on the left is
about four light years tall.
So four times 10
trillion kilometers.
So it's quite a difference
in scale,
four times 10 trillion
kilometers
versus the 400 times
magnification that we looked
at in the previous slide.
But the way this image was
created again, was intentional.
It was to talk about the science
and the science in this case,
is this idea of these immense
pillars of gas and dust
where these baby
stars are being made.
And to get across the point
of the dimensionality, we --
well, the image processers
on this specific data
set applied colors
in a very strategic way to
encourage that dimensionality
to be immediately
visible to the viewer.
And that was purely
by color selection.
So I'll talk a little bit
about more how we make
astronomy images in a second
but essentially for this
image, the colors were chosen
by chemical elements, by the
light emission due to them.
So red was from sulfur and
the blue color was assigned
to hydrogen and helium.
And I think green was
assigned to oxygen.
So it's kind of like
an elemental map
of the stuff that's going on in
this really beautiful nebula.
By choosing those colors,
now this is something we
can't see with our human eyes.
Even though it's mostly optical
light, our eyes are kind of puny
in the grand scheme of things
and we could never detect all
of this information with
just the eyes that we have.
So these telescopes give
us superhuman vision.
So when we're working
with our data,
it doesn't particularly
matter what colors these are
because it's not something we
could really observe directly.
So the color assignment was
meant to help further the idea
that this has dimension
and shape to it.
And so with blue being
more on the background
and the reds being
more in the foreground,
that idea of dimensionality
and shading, I think,
was really made a lot stronger.
When we think about things
like scale, which is, I think,
a really difficult thing to
talk about when you're looking
at something really, really
small or when you're looking
at something really, really big.
One of the easiest techniques
to do is to provide some sort
of sense of scale through
a physical representation.
So on the left here, we have
this really lovely louse
and I don't think that's
probably something I say
very often.
But it's grasping a
single strand of hair.
So that immediately gives
you a sense of scale.
But also context because
well, let's face it.
Lice, they like hair.
So it provides so much more
than just a little, you know,
something for it to hold on to.
It gives you that immediate idea
of scale and contextualization.
On the right is essentially
another idea of scale.
The idea here that he was trying
to show was that sometimes,
things that seem so
smooth are really not.
And the pollen grain
looking-like thing is actually a
printed full stop, a period.
And for scale, you can
also see the needle point
and then underneath
that is the razor.
So it's this idea of you know,
known things and looking at them
in a different way but still
providing a relationship
to each other.
Scale in astronomy is hard.
It's really hard.
So our sun is kind of small
in the grand scheme of things.
It's just an ordinary star.
It's kind of on the
smaller size.
It's not super exciting.
It's perfect for us.
Don't get me wrong.
I love our sun.
I'm not, you know,
dabbling at that much.
So when it comes to
talking scale, well,
you could fit maybe a
million Earths inside our sun.
So we can show the idea
of scale by positioning
that one single Earth
in relation
to this one outburst
coming out of the sun.
And that single outburst which
was not particularly big,
dwarfs the Earth by quite a lot.
Now, the issue is as soon
as you get beyond something
that's a little bit more doable
in size like the sun
is to bigger things,
how do you portray the scale in
a meaningful way to the viewer
who might not necessarily have
any sort of personal connection
to sizes of these things,
like not of us really do?
Scale bars have been
used for a while.
As you can see, Hooke
used quite a lot of them
in his Micrografia .
This is blue mold that's
been magnified, I think 200
or 300 times, really lovely.
Again, he's using the
circular view but this idea
of the scale bar
was really useful.
We apply scale bars
in astronomy as well.
In this case, however, the
scale is quite difficult.
We actually are looking here
at the El Gordo cluster
of galaxies.
This is the most
massive distant cluster
of galaxies we've ever been
able to detect with a mass
of about three quadrillion suns.
This image is seven
million light years across.
Again, light year, 10
trillion kilometers.
It's really huge.
We provide a scale in
[inaudible], not super helpful.
So typically, when I'm
talking about scale,
I really do like to
try to break it down,
at the very least,
into light years.
But even light years, I think,
are hard to really
grasp the size of them.
When we talk about how we
represent these objects
physically, I was always
struck by this image
from Micrografia
which is the flea.
And if you've ever seen it
in person, it's like the size
of a cat or maybe a
small dog even, right?
I think it's kind of
ironic because, you know,
fleas like cats and dogs.
So I don't know if that
was intentional or not.
But I've always thought
it was really funny.
But it's this idea of the
outsized, it adds such a sense
of drama and spectacle
for the viewer.
And I think spectacle might
perhaps be a little undersold
as a technique.
I really do appreciate
the artistic merit
that creating something
like this took
and what effect it has.
In astronomy, it's
difficult to go really big
because the objects are so huge.
So we can show something
on a wall.
I guess you guys are looking
at a pretty large version.
That's kind of cool.
We can go, you know, a little
bit more dimensional and big
and really the only reason
I chose this picture is
because when I was
looking through it,
I saw that Her Majesty
the Queen was in there.
I thought we would maybe
take a little quick stop
for all the talking this
morning and play a game.
What I thought we would do is
look at a few modern images
from microscopy because I didn't
want it to be just historical.
A lot of the things that I'll be
talking about and haven't talked
about so far reflect on new
just as much as the old.
And so here, I've actually
gathered pairs of images
from microscopy as well as
astronomy just to showcase some
of the unintentional
similarities that are
to be found in these
things across such very,
very different scales.
So if we look at the --
let's take the bottom right.
Now, one of these is
really big and one
of these is really small.
How many people think
the one on the left
of those two far right panels is
the really big one of the pair?
Just raise your hands.
How many think that
one's the big one?
A couple. How many think the one
on the very far right is
the biggest of the pair?
Oh, wow! All right.
It must be the field
that you're all in.
You're correct [laughter].
So the image on the far bottom
right is a quasar 3C273,
incredibly distant,
billions of light years away,
powered by this massive, super
massive black hole at its center
that is pumping out
this ridiculous stream
of high energy particles.
It's gargantuan.
And the image right
next to is -- oh, me --
which one is that one?
That one is not my image.
It is membrane fission.
So it's really small.
But I was struck by how
similar they look just
in their visual sense.
How about perhaps the
images on the upper left?
There are two red-like images.
Who thinks the one on the left
is the biggest of the pair?
Raise your hand.
I just want to see.
Yeah. And who thinks the one
on the right is the
bigger of the pair?
Oh, wow. So this one
was much more split.
So the image on the left
is actually stars dying
because that's my favorite
in the Small Magellanic Cloud
which is a really small
satellite mini-galaxy not too
far away from us but still,
it's like, I don't know,
100,000 light years away.
And then the image on its right
is Mycobacterium tuberculosis.
And when you look at
these images up close,
I don't know how
great your view is.
The visual resemblance
between the two is really
quite striking.
So the fact that we are able to
look at this from a microscope
for the one on the right and
through a telescope for the one
on the left is absolutely
incredible.
I'll just do the other pairs
really quickly for people
who want to finish
the game on their own.
Pair two is the sun
compared with Raji cells.
And those Raji cells can lead
to Epstein Barr syndrome.
Pair three, onion cells and
another dead star, my favorite.
So that's the ones here
on the bottom left.
Pair four is rabbit tongue
cells compared to Jupiter
so that's the upper right.
And the one underneath it is
a comparison between Mercury,
our planet and embryonic
stem cells.
Now I think, you know, a lot
of you got the answers right.
Not that you know, it's a quiz.
But I think it is -- there are
visual cues that you can follow,
resolution and scale
and structure.
But I just thought it
was really interesting
to see so many similarities.
And when I'm talking about
that visual language,
it still applies to modern
microscopy images as well
as astronomical images.
So I'm just going to
do a little brief segue
into what I do all day.
So this is an image of our sun
and it's actually showing
the many different kinds
of light that our sun emits.
One of the really important
tools in astronomy is the fact
that there is this entire
multi-wavelength spectrum
of information in order
to understand things
in the universe.
And we really need to understand
many different kinds of light
in order to grasp the
objects that we're looking at.
This is one of my favorite
objects in the entire universe.
And I get to see that because
essentially it's the first
object that the telescope that
I work for ever looked at.
It's Cassiopeia A which
is a star that exploded.
Yes, I know.
It's a super nova remnant.
It is about 10 to
11,000 light years away
so 10,000 time 10
trillion kilometers.
And we're looking
at it with data
from the Hubble Space
Telescope, quite beautiful,
showing this 10-million-degree
filamentary structure.
We look at that exact same
field of view that I've selected
from Chandra's X-ray Observatory
and we get a completely
different view
of the same patch of sky.
So utilizing different kinds
of light is really
important for us.
If we composite the
two images together,
we get a better sense
of what's going on.
Because as we noticed from the
exercise earlier, sometimes,
if you're looking at
an image like that,
if you don't have some
sort of recognizable sense
or if the fact that you know
there's an astronomy person
in front of you talking about
it, you might not be aware
that it is actually an
image of a universal scale
versus something small.
But images of the universe,
they start out looking
a little bit more
like this or maybe like that.
But really, it's this.
So these images start
out in this digital way.
We create them.
You know, these are not
giant cosmic selfies.
We have to create them from
the stream of ones and zeroes.
And the way we do that
is we have the object
in the sky quite far
away, Cassiopeia A
in this example,
10,000 light years.
That light has been
travelling for a while.
It's recorded by this spacecraft
and this is the Chandra
X-ray Observatory.
And then that information is
bundled up in the form of ones
and zeroes and sent down to my
laptop wherever that might be.
We then get to turn it into a
table which is very exciting.
This table essentially records
the distance of the location X
and Y, the amount of energy,
how long it was observed,
very fascinating
to look at, I know.
But then we use more software
and then we finally get a visual
representation of the object.
So we have quite a few steps
before it gets to here.
And this is pretty
far along already.
I've scaled it, removed
artifacts,
perhaps composited a couple
of observations together
to get a deeper data set.
And then the final
step is color.
Typically, we use again the
science to tell the story.
We have a perspective.
We are trying to get
something across.
And in this case, the
way we cut up the colors
and the energy cuts, we can
see the blue was assigned
to the highest energy x-rays.
The green, to the medium x-rays.
And the red to the
lowest energy x-rays
to create what we call
a chromatic ordering.
Now, it's like a weather map on
weather.com or the nightly news.
The point is to help fit
more information to add
to the information
quotient of this image.
It's important to see where that
high energy x-ray material is,
for example.
As you can probably
tell, it's along the rim
and that's essentially the
expanding shockwave going
out into space.
So we've colored
it this way here
but we could color
it a different way
for a different purpose.
For example, we put out a
release not that long ago
that had this image color-coded
by chemical element so similar
to the one I talked
about earlier.
And the whole point of
that image was to show
that essentially, the
elements that we have inside
of us come from,
they originate the --
original originals from stars
like this when they explode.
So we have this data.
We don't have to look
at it just in 2D.
We can look at it
in two D over time.
This is looking at
versions of the data
from 2000, 2002, 2004, and 2007.
And we can see that this
observation is changing
and that this image
is expanding.
And what we learned from
this is that outer shockwave
that I mentioned a
minute ago is traveling
at around 11 million
miles per hour.
So adding time to our
data, again adds more
to that information quotient.
But we wanted to do more so
we worked with a scientist,
Tracey DeLaney to figure out how
to create a 3D map of this data.
We included optical and infrared
data to get a stronger picture
and mapped it by using
the Doppler Effect
by a simple assumption of the
geometry that it was radiating
out from a specific point.
And also by borrowing
brain imaging software
from a local Boston hospital
because we didn't have our
own free software at the time.
So again, big and
small, who knows?
But this image is the
first time we're ever able
to see a data-driven map of
our friend, Cassiopeia A,
this exploded star
10,000 light years away,
10,000 times 10 trillion
kilometers.
And we're seeing it
in three dimensions.
Now, it does not look very
recognizable in that form
so we took a wire frame of
that data and we brought it
into a 3D software package
so that we could apply colors
and textures that
looked a little bit more
like this thing might look.
That made it look a little
bit more astronomical
to help give it that
visual contextualization.
And so, it's data-driven in this
sense but it's a step removed
from the last version
which is a step removed
from the version before
that, et cetera, et cetera.
So this is the first time we're
ever able to see through, below,
above, behind a star
that exploded 10,000
light years away,
10,000 times 10 trillion
kilometers.
But it was created by data.
We weren't quite done.
We thought, "Wouldn't it
be fun to hold this thing?"
Yes, we did.
So we worked with our friends
from the Smithsonian and then
over here but we figured
out how to 3D model
or a 3D print this 3D model
and we finally just last week,
figured out how to add
color to our 3D model.
So now, we can hold a
dead star in our hands.
And we can understand
in this case,
the various chemical elements so
where the sulfur is coming from.
I think that was the
red in this version,
where the silicon is coming
from, where is the iron.
And the only thing I noticed
just for posterity is that I had
to leave the jets at home
because they're so fragile
and I was on an early
flight this morning.
I just didn't want to deal so
just pretend there are a couple
of jets sticking out of that.
But yeah, so this is the first
time we could hold the dead star
in our hands.
Again, hugely scaled down.
This is about 40 million
billion times the area
of our sun and eight planets.
You could toss in Pluto.
It wouldn't make a difference
but it's really big, right.
And it's dynamic, as
I mentioned before.
It's changing over time.
So you're seeing it, you
know, small in plastic.
So take that for what it will.
It's another representation.
But we weren't done yet.
Let's see.
I think this is the only video
that does not play
on automatically.
Here we go.
I thought wouldn't it fun if we
can walk inside this dead star?
So we took it to
Brown University
and some fantastic
collaborators there.
We were able to create a
virtual reality version
of that same data.
And now, you can see this
is one of my students.
She is walking inside
a dead star.
The camera person
is outside the star
which is why it looks
like she's not it.
But she's in it.
Trust me. So she's walking
around inside a dead star,
Cassiopeia A, 10,000 light
years away, and she's inside it.
And this is data.
This is data representations.
So we've created many
different versions
of this one famous super nova
remnant and I think as --
I think Roger mentioned this
point, very collaborative.
This is not me doing this.
This is not one person
doing this.
This is just teams upon
teams of people working
to create different
versions of their data
for very specific reasons.
But they all started here.
All of these data versions came
out of this original
bit of code.
So really quick.
I thought [inaudible] to
do a little case study,
I guess, of images over time.
And it was this whole
idea of the image as truth
that I thought would
be really interesting.
I think there is this idea
that modern photography
has removed the objectivity
of these things or
subjectivity, I should say.
And that they are
more truthful now.
Well, perhaps but when we look
at this image from Galileo
of the moon, we already
heard there was an issue
with it, right?
So this is not "accurate
representation."
He was creating this
version for his own purposes
and it's really lovely.
We can look at this version
which is a daguerreotype
and that's essentially
a process that was kind
of like a precursor
to modern photography
that uses a combination of
chemical agents essentially
to create something that
looks very photographic.
This is the oldest
surviving daguerreotype
of the moon, by the way.
I think it was from
John Whipple.
And then, we can see the moon
from the Apollo missions.
And this was as Apollo 11
was on their way back home.
And I think this was maybe
10,000 nautical miles away.
And it was one of
them snapped a photo
and we have this
version of the moon.
Is that more real than
this one or this one?
Perhaps. Is it more truthful?
Perhaps. Then we
have this version.
This is using a special
nine-millimeter telescope,
super top of the line,
the
astrophotographer/astrophysicist
who's a friend of mine who's
working on this, Travis Rector,
got this great deep data set.
It's just incredible,
high resolution
that we're able to
see the moon in.
But he wanted to put
it in the perspective
of its cosmic background.
So he grabbed a shot from
a different telescope
of the exact placement of the
moon from the stars behind it.
So this was a composite of
the two images together.
You can't physically take
these two images as one just
because of the brightness
and the resolution issues.
So is this one more truthful?
Is this one more real?
And because you know, I'm paid
by NASA's Chandra Observatory,
this is a version from the
Chandra X-ray Observatory.
The x-rays are shown
in blue and mapped
over an optical image
of the same phase.
And here, it was really
useful for us to understand
where x-rays from the
moon were coming from
and they are essentially a
reflection of the solar x-rays.
But we understood that
fluorescence has happened here
and it helps resolve a
mystery that had been
around for decades
so it was cool.
Is this one more truthful?
So my last little
mini-story that I want to tell
because I'm sure the [inaudible]
is getting a little antsy is
just that it's one thing to
talk about how people like me
or teams of me create
images like this.
But when we talk about who
we're creating them from,
that's a whole other
thing together.
You can have as much data
in an archive as you want.
But that has potential value.
Data that's been visualized
for a specific point
but for a specific audience has
even more added value to it.
So we started a research project
called Aesthetics and Astronomy.
It's me and a couple
of other folks imaging,
psychologist, aesthetics types.
And we were able to
understand how experts
and non-experts approach images
of our universe quite
differently.
In this case, we're looking at
the Bullet Cluster of galaxies.
It's this really tremendous
image about where the separation
of normal matter and
dark matter occurs.
And it's actually a
visual representation
of that process happening
which we have never
been able to see before.
The normal matter is in
pink and this dark matter
of which there's an awful
lot of it in the universe
that we know very little
about, is shown in blue.
And when an astronomer
looks at this image,
they immediately want to know
what telescopes are involved.
So what's the science?
What's the interesting,
you know,
observational thing
going on here?
When a non-expert looks at
the same image, it's wow,
that's beautiful first.
Then eventually, they
want to know things
like well, what is it?
What does the scientist
see when he or she looks
at something like this?
The expert, after formulating
those first questions,
slowly drifts into,
"Wow, that's beautiful."
Or maybe, you might get a
"That's cool," if they're,
you know, a little
more on the down low.
But so, that idea of wonder
is immediate for a non-expert
and secondary for an expert.
Color, incredibly important.
As I mentioned, we're looking
at something we can't see
with our sad, puny
human eyes, right.
So does it matter
what colors I choose?
If it doesn't really
have anything to do
with the science story, in
this case, we're looking
at a galaxy, NGC 4696.
I think it's about 50
million light years away.
Relatively close in the
grand scheme of things.
There is this super
massive black hole inside
that white core that is spewing
out these high energy particles
and then causing all of this
material that you're looking
at to be super-heated.
This was the way the
image looked at first.
The main difference
between those two,
the x-ray is colored
blue in this version
and colored red in this version.
Now this image was meant to
be for a non-expert audience.
We were trying to talk about
the heat in this galaxy.
So which version should we
have released to the public?
Who likes the red version?
Raise your hands.
Yeah, who likes the blue?
All right.
You're a physicist,
aren't you [laughter]?
So physicists like this version
because in physics, blue is hot.
But the rest of us
non-physicists,
who says to their
kid, "Don't touch
that stove, it's blue hot?"
Maybe you do.
But I don't so the whole point
is color has a very specific
cultural context, a very
specific power to it.
And if you're trying to get a
point across, red versus blue?
It doesn't matter for the data.
The data does not care.
But it does matter for
who's looking at it.
Scale, I know [Inaudible]
talked about this briefly.
What I'm just bringing up
very quickly is that again,
scale is hard in astronomy
to do in a really well way.
But people at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York,
they typically spend about 17
seconds on standing in front
of a masterpiece, define
masterpiece how you will.
People looking at astronomical
images on a screen just
about the same amount of
time, that 17-second mark.
However, you add a scale bar and
it could have very minimal text,
just something like this,
doubles that, that viewing time
because it gives them
something to think about.
Now, why am I showing
this picture?
So this is one of my favorite
stories by an artist that --
I just love his taste.
This is Madame Henri-Francois
Riesener --
I don't speak French so
excuse my pronunciation --
by the artist Eugene
Delacroix, 1835.
Now, I'm not an artist or an
art expert or a historian.
If I were in a gallery at the
Smithsonian and there were tons
of pictures to look at,
I wouldn't know to look
at this one specifically.
But this woman was
the artist's aunt.
And really you can see kind
of like this frank tenderness,
I think, in the portrait.
But I just want to read
this one little bit.
She was known for her beauty.
Some 30 years before the
date of this portrait,
she served as a lady-in-waiting
to Empress Josephine
and having caught
Napoleon's eye,
engaged in a brief
liaison with him.
After she died, Delacroix wrote
to his friend, George Sand,
"Each of the beings necessary
to our existence who disappears,
takes away with him a
whole world of feelings
that no other relationship
can revive."
My husband's here.
I hope he would write
something like that about me
after I'm gone because that's a
pretty powerful letter, right?
But that immediately makes this
piece so much more interesting.
Now that I know the
story, I would stop.
It's the similar situation
in astronomy, right?
We see that this is
beautiful and now,
I can kind of see something in
there that I didn't see before.
But if we're just looking
at a picture such as Saturn
in ultraviolet light, it's great
to have scientific
purpose, absolutely.
But if we're trying
to communicate something
interesting about it,
the one thing that typically
gets people is that --
oh, if you can see
on the screen.
Let me see if I can -- oh, yeah.
There it is.
See that little dot?
That's Earth waving back
at the Cassini mission
that took this image.
So we are in the context of
this image taken very far away
from us and in a
different kind of light.
But that idea that we
can add to the story,
I think is really helpful.
And we found that when we
add really important, useful,
relevant, interesting
descriptions or images,
we increase the viewing
time dramatically,
not just the amount of time
it takes them to read the text
but also in just how much
people will ponder it.
But beyond just the viewing
time, the aesthetic appreciation
for this image improved
dramatically
when we had the contextual
information presented with it
than when it was
presented just on its own.
So there is a time for spectacle
and then there is
a time for context.
So, I'm pretty much done.
I'll just say, "I read books
about this stuff because I'm
so fascinated about it.
I'm really happy to
be here today to learn
from everybody else and see
what everybody else is doing.
But essentially, you
know, these images
of our universe are not
just cosmic selfies.
We create them.
We have a viewpoint.
We are people.
We have our biases.
We should be more transparent
with how we do them and why.
We try very hard to be for the
telescopes that I worked for,
using descriptions and having
features on how we made things
and breaking down the
image into various pieces.
But I just want to
end with this quote.
"By means of telescopes, there
is nothing so far distant
but maybe represented to
our view and by the help
of microscopes, there
is nothing so small
as to escape our inquiry.
Hence there is a new
visible world discovered
to the understanding."
That is Robert Hooke
from Micrografia .
I leave some websites.
If you want to see how
you did on the quiz,
you can go to
chandra.is.edu/micro.
If you want to learn more about
the research, go to the last one
in the list and then the
other ones are just probably
more obvious.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.